GOOD AFTERNOON THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
AND WELCOME EVERYONE OF THE
HEARING ROOM IS OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING. AND
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDING THE HEARING IS
ENCOURAGED TO WEAR MASKS AT LL
TIMES WHILE IN THE BUILDING. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BY VISITING
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE I KNOW
THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE IS
CONSIDERED PUBLIC COMMENT MAYBE
READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED. EVERYONE IS
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE. YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR BY USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE WE WILL ALLOW
FOR EACH BILL TAT'S HEARD TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. THAT WILL BE ALL OF
THE TESTIMONY THAT WE HEAR
OUTSIDE OF ANYBODYELSE WHO
WANTS TO- TESTIFY WHAT WE
LIMITED TO ONLY STATING YOUR
NAME AND ANY ORGANIZATION IF
THERE IS ONE THAT YOU REPRESENT.
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL WE
WILL NOT TAKE TESTIMONY AFTER
THE RECORDED WITNESSES THE TWO
FOR EACH OF THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE POSITION FOR EACH PIECE
OF LEGISLATION NOW IF YOU DO
WANT TO GIVE US ANY OTHER
INFORMATION YOU'RE WELCOME. TO
DO THAT BY SENDING US AN EMAIL
OR BY SENDING US ACTUAL SNAIL
MAIL AND WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
THAT CAN BE SEEN. WHEN WE GO TO
WITNESS TESTIMONY. WE WILL START
WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
CORE HERE IN THE ROOM. AND THEN
WILL MOVE TO THE TELEPHONE
SERVICE NOW TO USE OUR TELEPHONE
SERVICE THE NUMBER TO CALL IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ELEVEN HUNDRED IF YOU DIDN'T
WRITE THAT DOWN DO NOT PANIC
THAT INFORMATION IS ALL
AVAILABLE AGAIN ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WHICH YOU
CAN FIND THROUGH THE STATE'S
WEBSITE. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY AT. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE NINE. NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE AT TWENTY
NINETY THREE AND OUR STAFF WILL
TRY TO HELP YOU WITH ANY
TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT YOU HAVE.
AND IF YOU ARE ON HOLD WITH THE
OPERATO AND FOR SOME REASON
YOU'RE DROPPED OR YOU GET
THROUGH IN THE WRONG BUILT
DON'T. GIVE UP JUST CALL BACK
AGAIN TELL THEM EXACTLY WHAT
BILL YOU'RE HERE TO TESTIFY ON
WE WILL GET YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. NOW UNFORTUNATELY THE
ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE AND FLOOR PROCEEDINGS
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS. ANY
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ODERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. SUCH CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE. SPEAKING
LONGER THAN THE TIME ALLOTTED
DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THAT
PARTICULAR BILL AND OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACTS TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE COP DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT THAT PREVENTS US FROM
DOING THE PEOPLE'S WORK I WILL
TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WARNED THEM THAT
CONTINUE DESTRUCTIONS MAY RESULT
IN REMOVAL FROM THIS BUILDING.
WE WILL ALSO DOCUMENT ON THE
RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED
IN THE NATURE OF THE DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT. I MAY HAVE TO TEMPORARY
RELIEF RECESSED THE HEARING
HOPEFULLY NOT. AND IF THE
CONDUCT IS NOT STOP I WILL
REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE OF OUR
SERGEANTS IN A SUPPORTING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE BUILDING. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION.
OKAY WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN OUR HEARING WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM YET SO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN. WITH THE HEARING IN THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WILL RETURN
TO VOTES ONCE WE DO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE HAVE FIVE MEASURES ON
CONSENT WHICH WE WILL VOTE ON
LATER AND I'LL READ THOSE WHEN
WE GET TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL CALL OUR
FIRST AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. WELCOME AND YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY.
YOU DO NEED TO PUSH THE BUTTON
AT THE PODIUM.
OKAY THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT REQUIRED
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
TO CONSULT THE CALIFORNIA PLACES
HEALTHY AND THE X. TIED THAT UP
BY THE H. B. I. SCORE FOR THE
PROJECT AREA PRIOR TO BEGINNING
A PROJECT FREEWAY EXPANSION
PROJECTS ARE SOLD AS A MEANS TO
REDUCE CONGESTION HOWEVER
RESEARCH SHOWS US THAT THE
INCREASE CONGESTION BY
ENCOURAGING MORE DRIVING THAT'S
INCREASING HARMFUL EMISSIONS
THESE PROJECTS ALSO TEND TO THIS
PLACE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WERE ALREADY HOUSING
INSECURE. FREEWAY WIDENING AND
EXPANSION PROJECTS QUITE
ACQUISITION OF REAL PROPERTY
LEADING TO THE DISPLACEMENT OF
PRECEDENCE. MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE
LOST THEIR HOMES NATIONWIDE TO
FEDERAL ROAD PROJECTS OVER THE
LAST DECADE ACCORDING TO AN L.
A. TIMES ANALYSIS OF THE FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION DATA. IN MY
DISTRICT ALONE I HAVE SIX
FREEWAYS THAT TOOK MY DISTRICT
ARE IN A NUMBER OF A WIDE
ANYTHING EXPENSES ARE BEING
DISCUSSED ON A REGULAR BASIS
HOUSING A LOT OF ANXIETY TO. MY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OUT THERE
MOSTLY LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR- IN THAT AREA- I'M GONNA
KEEP IT SHORT. SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE
TODAY THAT THIS BILL IS TRYING
TO CUT. DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THIS DISCUSSION OUT THERE. I AM
TRYING TO COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
STILL SOME CONCERNS AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN OPPOSITION.
YOU TRY TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT. PROVIDES A
LITTLE BIT OF JUSTICE TO
COMMUNITIES LIKE MY WHAT ALSO
WORKS FOR URBAN OUT THERE. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY HAVE THE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF COMMERCE O'REILLY
EDITORIAL. AND MICHAEL DID N. F.
CREATIVE HOUSING ASSOCIATES AND
WANT TO THANK. YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU TWO
MINUTES FOR EACH WITNESS PLEASE
THEY'RE BOTH ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE FIND
THE TWO WITNESSES. FOR AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. YES GO
AHEAD. I I'M HERE MICHAEL DIDN'T
YOU WANT ME TO GO NOW. YES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MICHAEL
DETERMINE THAT I AM A CALIFORNIA
BASED HOUSEBUILDER SPECIALISING
IN BUILDING TRANSIT INTEGRATED
NEIGHBORHOODS MAINTAINED
RELATIVELY DENSE HOUSING AND
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION STATIONS MOST OF
OUR WORK INVOLVES HEALING THE
SCARS LEFT OVER BY INSENSITIVE
FREEWAY DEVELOPMENT THAT HAVE
PERPETUATED SUBURBAN SPRAWL AND
VERY LONG DISTANCE SINGLE
PASSENGER COMMUTING WHICH NOT
ONLY HAS THIS DEVELOPMENT
PARADIGM YOUR DIFFICULT LEE
CONTRIBUTED TO GLOBAL WARMING.
BUT IT HAS DEVASTATED ONCE
HEALTHY NEIGHBORHOODS EMOTIONAL
OFTEN BETTER GROWTH POPULAED BY
WORKING CLASS AND UNDER. HER
POPULATION. I UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME OF BY CALL TO THE BUILDING
THAT JUST. OF LATE A SEVENTY
SEVENTY EIGHT AS A JOB KILLER
WELL NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER
FROM THE TRUTH. JUST ARBITRARILY
CONSTRUCTING HOUSING DOES NOT
AGNOSTIC IT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE WHERE IT IS LOCATED.
FOUR FROM JOBS. REQUESTING
COMMUTE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGING AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
OR IS A HOUSING IN INFILL
LOCATIONS IN CITIES AND TOWNS
NEAR PUBLIC TRANSIT STATIONS
WHERE WORKING PEOPLE CAN TAKE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION TO WORK M.
FOR GOLD CAR OWNERSHIP. WHERE
WHICH BURDENS THEM WITH TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY. THIS
IS WHAT THIS LEGISLATION IS
ABOUT IS ABOUT THE FUTURE USS
POPULATIONS WHO REALLY NEED IT.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE
YESTERDAY TO ADVANCE AB SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT OUT OF COMMITTEES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
WE HAVE MAY OF WELL.
OPERATOR IF THAT PERSON PLEASE
PRESS YES THEY COULD PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. SHE. AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
PERSON'S NAME AGAIN. MAYOR OR
RALLY OUT REBELLO. THE SYSTEM.
AND THEIR BODY OF COULD YOU
PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO AT THIS
TIME.
PERHAPS IF WE CAN'T FIND THE
MAYOR WE CAN MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION WITNESS AND THEN COME
BACK UP SORRY THERE'S THIS WEIRD
PROCARE THROUGH OKAY WE'LL JUST
WE'LL WE'LL STAND BY. BUT I
DON'T SHOW THEM QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. BUT ONE MOMENT. JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT THANK YOU. YEAH
THEY HAVE ALL YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS FOR YOUR. HERE
THANK YOU I'M- I WORK. FOR I'LL
KEEP SEVENTY I DON'T THE YOU'RE
A BEAUTY. HOW OF OTHER RESIDENTS
SURROUNDED BY INDUSTRY. ONE OF
THE HIGHEST EVERYTHING. COMPLY
THINK THE WAY IN WHICH JANET IN
THE- WE HAVE TO PARK IN WHICH
SEPARATE. NOT RECOGNIZE. THANK
THANK RIGHT OKAY OR MAY. I HAVE
BEEN PART. SO OFTEN OF MY A BOX
AND THANK. FROM OFFICE RIGHT HE.
DURING CONTENT WE DESERVE BETTER
WE ALL ARE KEEP. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TANK. HELLO EVERYONE MY IS
THAT BOY I AM I NEED OLD AND A
RESIDENT OF CRIME BECAUSE YOU
SHOULD ALREADY THE CITY I SUFFER
FROM AS MINOR. BUT YOU IT HARD
FOR ME WHEN I FOR WILL CALL. I'M
NOT MALE BUT I KNOW EQUALITY IN
QUALITY IN VERY BAD BECAUSE OF
AND ROADS GOING NOT MY
PRESCHOOLERS NOT NEXT TO THE.
FIVE WE WILL I NOT PLAY I USED
TO PLAY HARDBALL THE WATER. WE
FROM. ALL MY TO FOUR EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN SOME EIGHT ME LIKE
FOR AND I. WOULD LOVE. TO PLAY
AND ANOTHER. THANK YOU.
YOU WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES APIECE
- WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. MIKE
RECCO THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR
. MY NAME IS MARC WATTS I'M
REPRESENTING TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA THE TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS A PEOPLE WHO BUILD
REPAIR- THIS STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM- FIRST I'D LIKE TO START
BY CANNELLA JIM THAT WE ENJOYED
A VERY PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR'S. OFFICE AND
STAFF A WEEK AND A HALF AGO AND
THAT LED US TO TAKE OF OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION RATHER
THAN AN OUTRIGHT OPPOSE SO IS
BENEFICIAL FOR THEM AND
BENEFICIAL FOR US. WE ORIGINALLY
FOUND THE MEASURE TO BE VERY
RESTRICTIVE AND BELIEVE THAT
WOULD POTENTIALLY LOCK UP THE
ENTIRE CORRIDORS WITHIN THE
STATE THAT ARE BENEFICIAL ROUTES
FOR MOVING PEOPLE AND GOODS-
HOWEVER WE ALSO FOR FULLY
BEHIND THE- THE GENESIS OF THE
BILL. SAID WHICH IS A STRONG
DESIRE TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO
COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCING CALIFORNIA'S WORST
AIR QUALITY. AND FREQUENTLY
LOCATED NEAR HIGHWAYS AND
ROADWAYS THAT- THE STATE IS
IMPLEMENTED. BUT AS WE DISCUSSED
WITH THE OFFICE STAFF WE SUGGEST
THAT THE BILL BE AMENDED TO
ELIMINATE THE DIRECT TIÞN TO THE
INDEX. AS WE FIND THAT ELEMENT
TO BE INAPPROPRIATE THE STATE
GENCY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO FACE
IT'S CRITICAL FUNDING AND
STAFFING- DECISIONS ON
METHODOLOGIES OF A THIRD PARTY
ENTITY. AND THAT THOSE POSH
THOSE- METHODOLOGIES COULD
CHANGE OVER TIME. WITHOUT MUCH
PUBLIC INPUT AND IT'S OF CONCERN
TO US SECONDLY WE ALSO FIND THE
STATUTORY THRESHOLD LIMIT BUILT
IN. FOR THE CONSULT CONSULTATION
THE THIRTY PERCENTILE STANDARD.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE. 50%
BELOW THE FIFTIETH PERCENTILE NO
MATTER WHAT THE UNDERLYING
NUMBERS ARE IN FACTORS ARE SO
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IT BUT
NEVERTHELESS WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND WOULD LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING. CLOSELY
WITH- THE AUTHORS OFFICE IF THE
BILL PASSES OUT OF COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU NECKLACE PLEASE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND PADAM SHARON
MEMBERS I'M WHERE A TOP. HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
REGRETTABLY WE TOO ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. I'M WE ARE SENSITIVE
AND APPRECIATE THE- THE REASON
BEHIND THE BILL AND- WE JUST
THINK THAT THE BILL AS IT'S
CURRENTLY DRAFTED IS FAR TOO
BROAD IT IS RESTRICTIVE. I'M
ALSO FELL COUNTIES INCLUDING
OURS WHEN WE WENT TO THE VOTERS
TO ASK- ARE VOTERS TO. PAY AN
EXTRA HALF CENT SALES TAX TO
FUND TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS.
WE DID SO BY GIVING THEM A LIST
OF PROJECTS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET FUNDED. I'M WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO FILL THE TOOK TO
FINISH THOSE PROJECTS WE'RE
WORKING OUR WAY THROUGH THAT
LIST OF PROJECTS RIGHT NOW. BUT
THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT US FROM
COMPLETING THAT LIST SOME OF
THOSE PROJECTS DO FALL WITHIN
THE DEFINITION THAT'S INCLUDED
IN THE BILL. SO WE NEED CAUGHT
BETWIXT AND BETWEEN BETWEEN TWO
LAWS WE HAVE A AN ABSOLUTELY
L'APPLICATION TO- TO FINISH THE
PROJECTS THAT WE TOLD THE VOTERS
WE WOULD. AND YET THIS BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT US UNFORTUNATELY
FROM DOING THAT. AND THEN- L. O.
WE DO THINK THE BILL IS
PARTICULARLY BROAD. WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE IN THE-
PRODUCTION PHASE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT PHASE.
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TAKE A
VERY LONG TIME TO- TO BRING TO
TH TO FRUITION. THE BILL DOESN'T
DISCUSS WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
THOSE PROJECTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN DEVELOPMENT AND SO
WE COULD HOLD THE PROJECT
MIDWAY. WE DON'T THINK THAT
MAKES SENSE AND LASTLY WOULD SAY
SOME OF THE THESE PROJECTS THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON EVEN ON THE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM ARE CONSISTENT
WITH OUR OUR SCS. THEY COULD BE
DONE IN WITH- THE PURPOSE OF.
HOW A MEDICARE- CONGESTION
MITIGATION. BUT ACTUALLY WOULD
HELP SOME OF THOSE AND SOME OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT SURROUND.
ON THE PROJECTS AND SO AGAIN WE
THINK IT'S OVERLY BROAD WE
REALLY DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD BUT AT THIS
POINT. WITH THE BILL AS DRAFTED
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MODEL YOU STAY THERE IN CASES
QUESTIONS FOR YOU LATER. THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IT THIS WAY
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST HAVE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO IS. IN
FAVOR IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION TO COME UP TO THE
MIKE. YOUR YOUR ME TO TESTIMONY
AND THEN WE MOVED TO OPPOSITION
THEN WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. FOR ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. HELLO JOINT
IMPENETRABLE ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIAN B. AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF AB. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
SEEING NO MORE ANYBODY OPPOSED
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HE'S
COME TO THE MIKE. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. SILVIO
PRIMECAP CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION AND THIS HAS BEEN
LABELED AS A HOUSING KILLER
THANK YOU. REXTON BEHIND WITH
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. JOHN MOFFETT ON
BEHALF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JAMES THEREAFTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
AND LECTURE LINE OPPOSITION WITH
MARC WATTS AND TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
WANTING TO TESTIFY BEFORE OR
AGAINST THE LEGISLATION. OKAY
LET'S MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
NOW- OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMENIF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO IT. AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAT THAN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. BY TWENTY SIX
PLEASE RE QUEUE. NEXTCODE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS SANTIAGO WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. NEXT MODEL LINE
NUMBER FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IT'S OVER MATTERS WITH ACTED SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY WHERE IN SUPPORT
. THAT SCORE LINE NUMBER FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREETINGS
CHAIR I AM GETTING ARE ON HOLD
POLICY ADVOCATE FOR CLIMATE PLAN
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANKS WOULD ALIGN NUMBER
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. MADAM CHAIR MEMBER JIM GRAHAM
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS- IN OPPOSITION LEFT
AMENDED. THANK YOU. NEXT WATER
LINE NUMBER FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PHILIPPE IT WENT THIS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS IN OPPOSITION. NOW THE
LINE NUMBER FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN I MOM WITH MOUNT
UNION BEING WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
WILL NOW GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL
SNYDER WITH THE STRUCTURE FOR
NOW THEN THE CANDLE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
NUMBER LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MARK
BROOKS **** I LIVE IN A CITY
SEGREGATED BY FREEWAY IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW GO TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS ADAM
BOOKBINDER ON BEHALF OF NIMBY
ACTION SUPPORTING AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. WELL
NOW GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARLA ASPECT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASPHALT
PAVEMENT ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. I'M NOT GOING TO
LIE NUMBER THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBER
MONNING WROTE ON BEHALF OF GOING
ON THE TWO POINT EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. I'M NOT
GOING TO LIE NUMBER FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DISCARDED RIBBON
WITH THE NATURALRESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. I'M NOT GONNA LIE NUMBER
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DURING THE SALLY FROM%
BANK CITY I'M STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. I'M NOT GONNA
LIE NUMBER TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO%
AHEAD. YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH ENTER
LEWIS- TREATS FOR ALL IN LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY SEVENTY SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
LIE NUMBER THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AND THIS IS ALL
OF THE EXCITEMENT WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ALONGSIDE
CLIMATE RESULT. CENTRAL VALLEY
AIR QUALITY COALITION CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE LITTLE
MANILA RISING CATHOLIC CHARITIES
DIOCESE OF STOCKTON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA WHAT TRANSFORMED AND
HELLEBUYCK THANK YOU. WELL
NUMBER LINE NUMBER FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE THIS
IS ABOUT THE FISH FROM CULVER
CITY ELLEN A HALF MILE AWAY FROM
THE FREEWAY AND- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. I'M NOT GONNA
LIE NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TODD BLOOM STEIN
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION OPPOSED
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. I'M NOT GONNA LIE NUMBER
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS A DAVID BARBOZA ON
BEHALF OF ABUNDANT HOUSING LA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN MAYES GENTLEMAN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
LONDON ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR NEXT BUT
PARTY'S.
IT'S JUST ONE MORE MOMENT. WELL
NUMBER LINE NUMBER SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY NOT MAIN MENU SHOW THE
GREAT SEND THEM BECAUSE THE
PRINTER LOOKING ASSOCIATION
UNDER UNDER COMMUNITY IN
NORTHERN LONG BEACH I'M SUPPORT
OF MAYBE A. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
LIE NUMBER SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE
LINER I AM CHAIR OF THE BICYCLE
PEDESTRIAN ADVISORY COMMITTEE IN
CULVER CITY BUT I'M SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF AND I'M IN FAVOR A. B. IT
IS SOMETIMES THANK YOU. ON THE
OTHER LINE NUMBER SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS KIRK DAVIS PASCO CHAIR OF THE
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY NORTH
PALM BEACH AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
AND YOUR PERSON AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THREE
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
CALL IN AND DOING IT IN A WAY
THAT'S THAT'S THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF HOW TO DO CALLING
TESTIMONY- WITH THAT WE WILL
COME BACK TO THE- COMMITTEE TO
SEE IF ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. THE KALRA THANK
MANAGER AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR- AND- I DEFINITELY AM.
WILL THE INTENTION IS A VERY
POSITIVE ONE- BUT THIS
LEGISLATION- AND I THINK THAT
EVEN LISTENING TO THE OPPOSITION
THAT THERE'S BEEN MOVEMENT AND-
BASED UPON THE FACT THAT
CONVERSATIONS ARE ONGOING
THERE'S BEEN MOVEMENT IN THE
POSITIVE DIRECTION- WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY AND HOPE
THAT THE CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE
BOTH WITH THE OPPOSITION AT THE
DESK AS WELL AS THOSE THAT-
SPOKE HERE TODAY. THANK YOU. MR
FONG. MY QUESTION IS THE AUTHOR
BUT MAYBE THE- THE OPPONENTS CAN
ALSO- CHIME IN TOO BUT- MY
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS THAT.
IT WOULD POTENTIALLY MAKE
CONGESTION WORSE THIS BILL WOULD
BAN PROJECTS- THAT ARE DESIGNED
TO REDUCE TRAFFIC CONGESTION AND
CONGESTED CORRIDORS. AND SO A
LOT OF THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
SLATED FOR CONSTRUCTION THAT ARE
ALREADY UNDERWAY OR THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH THE REVIEW PROCESS
THIS BILL- AT THE WAY I READ IT.
WOULD WOULD HAVE THESE PROJECTS
STOP AT A TIME WHEN WE NEED TO.
ENCOURAGE GOOD MOVEMENTS WITH
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN CHALLENGES
EVERYTHING ELSE- WE ALSO NEED TO
BE INVESTING IN IN CRITICAL
FREIGHT CORRIDORS WHICH A LOT OF
THESE PROJECTS ARE INTO SO HOW
HOW WHAT IS YOUR- WHAT IS YOUR
RESPONSE. TO THAT. THANK YOU I
ACTUALLY LIVE OFF OF ONE OF
THOSE GOODS MOVEMENT ALTHOUGH
THAT'S COMING INTO THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH AND LA AND UP ON THE
SEVEN TEN FREEWAY AND READ
THROUGH MY DISTRICT EITHER THE
SEVEN TEN TO THE RAILYARD. OR AT
THE SIX OH FIVE. ON AND ALL THE
OTHER FREE WITH A THICK SIDE.
ARE IN SO A GREAT WAY TO HELP IS
TO GET US OUT OF OUR CARS AND
INVEST IN PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
WE HAVE. A GOAL LINE IN THE AREA
WE HAVE AN ORANGE LAND AREA ALL
THAT WERE INITIALLY SLATED TO BE
COMPLETED IN TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT.
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN PUSHING HARD
TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN IN THIS
COUNTRY AND I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO GET THERE. ARE OUT THERE TO
HELP THOSE GOODS MOVEMENTS MOVE
I WANT THEM TO MOVE ALSO THERE
ARE IMPORTANT TO OUR- ECONOMY.
AS WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
PROJECTS WE HAVE MORE RESEARCH
AND MORE DATA SHOWING US THAT
SOMETIMES WHAT WE THINK WE ARE
HELPING WITH CONGESTION WERE
ACTUALLY DOING THE OPPOSITE. AND
SO I THINK FOR MYSELF IT'S
TAKING WHAT WE'VE LEARNED THANK
IN OUR COMMITMENT TO EQUITY AND
HOW TO RETHINK THIS IT BY NO
MEANS I TRY TO PRETEND THAT THIS
BILL IS PERFECT. BUT AS WE
CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE
OPPOSITION IS HOW DO WE CREATE
SOMETHING BETTER I THINK AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE'RE ALL
COMMITTED TO SOMETHING THAT'S
MORE EQUITABLE ARE MOLD MORE
JUST THE ONLY PIECE I DID ON
THE- FROM THE OPPOSITE. IS ABLE.
THIS A HOUSING KILLER WHEN
DISPLACING FOR EXAMPLE. TWO
THOUSAND FAMILIES ON THE
SEVENTEEN PREVIOUS SOUNDS LIKE A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A HEALTHY
COLOR TO ME. OTHERWISE I'LL BUT
I AM COMMITTED TO FINDING IN
THAT SPOT IF THERE ARE PROJECTS
THAT. ARE NEEDED FOR SAFETY.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO GET IN THE
MIDDLE OF THOSE. I THINK SOME OF
THE SENSORS THAT HAVE. BEEN
BROUGHT UP THERE IS A PATH. WAY
FORWARD BUT I THINK THE REALITY
IS THAT SOME DECISIONS WERE MADE
TWENTY YEARS AGO. THEY NOT
REALLY. TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION ALL THAT WE'VE
LEARNED IN THE TWENTY YEARS AND
WE NEED EVERYTHING SOME OF THOSE
IDEAS AND WE'RE STARTING TO IN
PLACES. WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
DOING THAT CONSISTENTLY ACROSS
THE STATE NOT JUST IN SOME
POCKETS. NO I'M SORRY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HI I USED TO KNOW HOW
TO DO THIS- I THINK. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND THAT'S WHY WE
WERE GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR
STAFF TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
BECAUSE- WE THINK. SEEK WHAT
NEPA IDENTIFIES AND HAS
CONSULTATION PROCESSES AND COMES
UP WITH MITIGATION PROGRAMS.
THAT AVOID CONFLICTS THAT ARE
AVOIDABLE. AND WE THINK THAT'S
MUCH MORE PREFERABLE THAN
HANGING- PROJECTS FUTURE ON A-
ON AN INDEX. THAT COULD CHANGE
FROM TIME TO TIME DEPENDING UPON
WHETHER DEPENDING UPON.
MEASUREMENTS AND OTHER. OTHER
THINGS SO WE'RE SATISFIED WITH
THE WAY. THE PROCESS WORKS NOW-
SOMETIMES WE'D LIKE TO SEIZE THE
BIT MORE STREAMLINING IN IN THE
SEQUEL AREA BUT- THIS. PURPOSE I
THINK WE THINK IT'S SET UP TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT. I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WHICH IS IDENTIFIED
THOSE. ISSUES NEED TO BE
MITIGATED TO AVOID THE IMPACTS
ON THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES OF.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE AT THIS POINT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO DO MR
FONG I WULD I WOULD JUST LOVE
IT MAYBE I'LL JUST CONCLUDE BY
SAYING THAT- YOU KNOW WITH WITH
TRAFFIC CONGESTION AND WITH
BOTTLENECKS- YOU KNOW WE SHOULD
BE INVESTING MORE RESOURCES.
INTO ADDRESSING THOSE THOSE-
THOSE CHALLENGES IN THOSE
IMPACTS SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
EFFICIENT FLOW AND THAT WE DON'T
HAVE BOTTLENECKS AND CONGESTION-
AND I'M MY I'M AFRAID THAT THIS
BILL WOULD ACTUALLY PROHIBITS IT
FUNDING. AND SO FOR THAT REASON
I CAN'T SUPPORT TODAY. I
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK THERE'S
LOTS OF WAYS TO ADDRESS
CONGESTION AT THIS AND ALWAYS
HAVE TO BE A FREEWAY EXPANSION
YOU KNOW I THINK EXPLAINED THAT
INCLUDING GETTING. INDIVIDUALS
OUT OF OUR CARS. I IS THE WAY WE
SAW IT DURING THE PANDEMIC WHO
ARE NOT DRIVING OUR CARS AND THE
STRIKES WERE FLOWING AT RECORD.
RECORD NUMBER OF TRUCKS OR
LEAVING THE PORT AND FLOWING TO
THE SEVEN TEMPE WAY INTO. IT
REGARDING COMMERCE. OUT THERE
AND SO THERE ARE THINGS LOTS OF
OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN BEST
DOLLARS. THAT MIGHT MAKE MORE
SENSE THAT ALLOW THE EFFICIENT
MOVE OF BUSINESSMEN'S. I WANT
THAT EFFICIENT MOVE A GOOD
MOVEMENT THAT MEANS CLEANER AIR
FOR ME WE'RE NOT JUST SITTING
AROUND SECOND TRAFFIC IDOLING.
AT THE OTHER DAY 75% OF MY AIR
POLLUTION ISSUES IN MY BACKYARD
ARE BECAUSE OF ALL THE TRUCKS
THAT OFTENTIMES ARE. I DON'T
THINK. I'M GETTING US OUT OF OUT
OF THEIR WAY IT'S HELPFUL. THANK
YOU- JUST KIND OF WANT TO JUMP
ON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. COMMENTS
THERE. I SAT ON- ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
DURING MY TIME WE OBVIOUSLY
APPROVED A LOT OF PROJECTS IN
THESE PROJECTS DON'T JUST HAPPEN
THEY TAKE FIVE YEARS SOMETIMES
TEN YEARS. SO MIKE ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS AS- WHAT ABOUT THESE
PROJECTS THAT ARE READY. YOU
KNOW. ON ON THE BOOKS BUT THEY
HAVEN'T STARTED EVER BROKEN
GROUND. WHAT GOES WHAT HAPPENS
TO THEM AND THEN ALSO IT
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND WHERE. YOU
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE LIVING. BUT
ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL. IT'S
SUCH IN THE STATE OF MY DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT. WE JUST WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE AREA OF THEIR
FOR. FOR TRANSIT FOR RAIL- IT
IT. IS JUST NOT MADE UP THERE
LIKE IT IS IN THE BIGGER CITIES
LIKE THAT SO. I UNDERSTAND. THIS
WOULD PROBABLY BE A GOOD PROJECT
FOR WHERE YOU'RE LIVING BUT IT'S
NOT ALWAYS THAT FOR EVERYONE
ELSE SO. I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
WAYS OF MAKING THIS WHERE IT'S
BASICALLY. A REGIONAL OR ITS YOU
KNOW IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE A VERY
WANTS TO. YOU KNOW DO THAT THEY
CAN DO IT BUT NOT PUTTING ACROSS
THE STATE BECAUSE THAT'S- WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN. WE DO SOMETHING
LIKE THAT IT'S NOT ALWAYS GREAT
FOR EVERYBODY. BUT I THINK WHAT
HAPPENS TO THOSE PROJECTS THAT
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED. AND
FUNDED. I WOULD SAY THAT WE ARE
IF I. IF INITIALLY THERE WAS A
DEBT TO STOP ALL THREE WEEK
CONSTRUCTIONS AND I THINK. TO BE
SENSITIVE TO BECAME. OR
THOUGHTFUL AND MINDFUL CREATING
A PROCESS WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND THIS BILL INTO
WERE OPEN TO.CONTINUING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH. THE OPPOSITION
TO TRY TO. KEEP MOVING AND THE
PRICE DIRECTION. TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE EVERYBODY ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND WE'RE NOT THE REALITY IS
THAT IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA AND
THE HISTORY. THESE FREEWAYS HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THOSE ARE THE COMMUNITIES ON
TRYING TO PROTECT AND IF WE
COULD CRAFT TOGETHER. I WANT TO
BE THE STAKEHOLDERS IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION I THINK WE HAVE
THAT SIMILAR COMMITMENT. HAVE
TOGETHER AMENDMENTS COME OPEN TO
THAT AT THIS VERY MOMENT. I
DON'T HAVE THAT I HAVE A COUPLE
OF FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN ENGAGING
IN DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE TO THE
OPPOSITION. THAT ALSO I'M
EXCITED THAT THEY'RE OPEN TO US
FOR YOU NOT THAT. THAT'S SWEET
SPOT AND SO I WELCOME THEM TO
TABLE I DON'T HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS FOR YOU. TODAY- WE WERE
START IN SOME PLACE IN THE
PROCESS AND- IF YOU LOOK AT MY-
RECORD OF. TEN I TRIED TO GET TO
THAT CONSENSUS I TRY TO FIND
THAT. SWEET SPOT TO THAT WORLD
WOULD YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE COMFORTABLE ENOUGH WITH. HI
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I'LL- I'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
HAPPENS TO THAT'S MY CONCERN TWO
GAME THERE'S A LOT OF PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN FUNDED. THAT ARE
SITTING THERE JUST READY TO GO
FORWARD WHAT HAPPENS TO ALL OF
THOSE AT THIS BILL PASSES DOWN
THE LINE- THE SENATE- WHAT
HAPPENED TO THOSE PROJECTS
ESPECIALLY A LOT OF THESE
PROJECTS FOR OUR- DISTRICT. ARE
FUNDED BY MEASURE M. TOO SO
THERE'S TAXES THAT PEOPLE READY
PAID. WHERE THEY GO SO. I THINK
THAT'S GREAT I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEEING WHAT YOU GUYS CAN DO.
AND THIS ONLY LIMIT STATE.
FUNDING ON THE STATE DOLLARS
THIS ELIMINATE ANY OF YOUR-
LOCAL TAX DOLLARS THAT YOU'RE
VOTERS HAVE. APPROVED RIGHT BUT
THOSE THOSE TAX DOLLARS WITH
CHIANG FOR THE PROJECT. SO IF
THEY CAN'T OF THE PROJECT. THERE
GO THOSE TECHNOLOGIES SAID. I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW YOU
GUYS WORK TOGETHER. THANK YOU.
MISTER LEE. I SAW A THANKED THE
OFFERING THE BILL FORWARD OUT.
I'M SORRY THAT I MISSED YOUR
POSITION BEGINNING BUT I THINK
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL. AND
AS WE PRIORITIZE MOVING PEOPLE
AND GOODS NOT JUST CARS THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN DOING THAT.
OKAY A LOT OF DEVELOPED
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD ARE EQUAL
PEERS OF POPULATION AND ECONOMY.
THAT I PRIORITIZE. ALMOST
TRANSITION OT JUST THE CAR SO I
THINK THIS IS WORTH MOVING
TOWARDS. AND I REALLY LIKE IT
AND I KNOW I'VE GOT FAITH IN YOU
THAT YOU WILL WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO FIGURE OUT THAT
SWEET SPOT. WHERE IT IS BUT- I
LIKE TO ADD MY NAME IS CO AUTHOR
IF YOU SO. ARE ABLE TO DO SO
THANK YOU. APPETITEGO THE DAILY
THANK YOU WERE. I WANT TO FLUSH
OUT A LITTLE BIT WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE- DETAILS
YOU'D LIKE TO. OBTAIN THROUGH
YOUR PROPOSAL. VERSES THE
EXISTING SYKORA. MECHANISM WHAT
WHAT ADDITIONAL WHAT REALLY IS
THE DIFFERENCE I WOULD SAY THAT
BY LEAVING EXAMPLE WHEN YOU CAN
DISPLACE A THOUSAND LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ALONG THE SEVEN TEN
FREEWAY- WE HAVE A PROBLEM THE
TO HEALTH IN A SECURE AREA WE
KNOW THAT THAT MORE TRAFFIC JUST
BEFORE POLLUTION ALSO AND SO THE
SYSTEM IS FAILING THEM WOULDN'T.
BUT WOULDN'T THAT. EXAMPLE BE
COVERED UNDER SEQUEL NO BECAUSE
YOU COULD ACTUALLY MITIGATE.
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD WITH
ENOUGH TO BE IN THAT BACKYARD
THAT YOU ARE IN THAT COMMUNITY
THAT YOU ARE AFFECTING THE HAVE
A SEPARATE BILL FOR THAT IF THAT
WERE TO PASS MAYBE IT WOULD BE
COVERED SO YOU'RE YOU. YOU
REALLY. DON'T WANT ANYONE. TO
EVER BE DISPLACED UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES I DON'T WALLOW FOR
A COMMUNITY FOR A FREEWAY
WIDENING RICH POOR WHITE PEOPLE
OF COLOR YOU DON'T WANT AYONE
DISPLACED NO THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY TRYING TO FOCUS ON
LOW INCOME DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IT'S NOT TRYING TO
SAY EVERYBODY WE ARE PRIOR IT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EQUITY AND
PROTECTING THOSE COMMUNITIES. MY
POINT IS. THOSE DETAILS. SHOULD
BE COVERED UNDER THE SEQUEL
PROCESS. NOT WHAT YOU CAN DO IT
ANYWHERE ELSE THE MITIGATION FOR
SECRET DOES NOT NEED TO HAPPEN
IN THE COMMUNITY. THAT IS BEING
AFFECTED. AND YOU DON'T WANT
THAT. NOT NOT FOR NOT FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY THAT'S ALREADY
NOT FOR A COMMUNITY THAT HAS
EXTRADITION THE GENERATION AFTER
GENERATION TOLD. THAT THEY ARE
SACRIFICING FOR EVERYONE ELSE
THIS PROGRESS THAT'S WHAT
CONTENTLY HAPPENS AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DATA TO COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR IS LOOKING COMMUNITIES
THAT IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. I
KEEP GETTING TOLD. THEY ARE AN
AFTERTHOUGHT AND SO IF I. AM ALL
I'M SAYING IS THAT THEY SHOULD
NOT BE AN AFTER THOUGHT HE WE'RE
GOING TO BE WITH EQUITY. WE
SHOULD BE PUTTING THAT AT THE
FOREFRONT. IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO HAVE SOME SPECIFICS ABOUT
THOSE VERY FOLKS WHO WERE
PROMISED SOMETHING. AND THEN THE
PROMISE WAS RENEGED I DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY WERE PROMISED
ANYTHING- A LOT OF TIMES THEY
GET A MINUTE THE MAIN PUSHED OUT
OR OTHER WAYS AND THEN DONNA
CERTAINLY END UP AND HOW THEME
OR END UP IN A BETTER SITUATION. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE. WELL I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR HER YEARS
OF WORK ON AIR QUALITY ISSUES IN
EQUITY ISSUES AND THERE'S BEEN A
CERTAINLY A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF THESE LARGE
FREEWAY PROJECTS ON LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES- OVER THE YEARS AND
CERTAINLY- PUTTING AN EQUITY
LENS ON THAT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S LONG OVERDUE AND
CERTAINLY SEE QUITE NEED A
NEARBY HAVE NOT DONE NEARLY
ENOUGH IN THE PAST TWO. I TAKE
THESE IMPACTS INTO ACCOUNT AND
THE OUR HIGHWAY NETWORK AND
WHERE ARE LARGE HIGHWAYS HAVE
BEEN PUT DEFINITELY SHOWS THAT I
DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR MS TOP
BECAUSE SOMETHING THAT YOU SAID-
INTERESTED ME AND I'M JUST
CURIOUS SO WHEN YOU PUT PROJECTS
IN FRONT OF THE VOTERS LIKE YOU
DID IN ORANGE COUNTY WHAT
EXACTLY DOES THAT LOOK LIKE SO
IF I GET MY BALLOT IN THE MAIL
DOES THAT MEAN THAT NEXT TO THAT
PARTICULAR. ITEM THERE'S A
LAUNDRY LIST OF PROJECTS AND SO
WHEN I VTE FOR IT I SEE EVERY
SINGLE PROJECT EVERY INTERCHANGE
EVERY ROAD THAT IS GOING TO BE
FUNDED BY THAT I'M TALKING TO
FOR A LITTLE BIT TO MY COLLEAGUE
HERE MR WATCH BUT- BUT BUT THE
SHORT ANSWER IS YES THOSE
PROJECTS ARE INGRAINED WITHIN
THE BALLOT INITIATIVE BUT IF I
DON'T YOU THINK IT ON THE BALLOT
AND I'LL LEAVE IT IS SO WHERE
WOULD SOMEBODY SO SOMEBODY WOULD
HAVE TO WHAT GO AND LOOK ON
WEBSITES SOMEWHERE AND LOOK AT
THAT. SO YOU'RE YES SO WHEN THEY
OPEN THE BALLOT IN THEIR VOTING.
MY GUESS IS IT SAYS LIKE. MONEY
TO HELP WITH. CONGESTION OR
TRANSPORTATION ORANGE COUNTY. I
BELIEVE THEY ARE DONE BY POTS OF
MONEY TYPE TYPES OF PROJECTS-
BUT THE INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS
WOULD HAVE TO BE IDENTIFIED
ELSEWHERE. AND AS OF SIGNIFICANT
COMMUNITY OUTREACH- EFFORT IS
MADE IN THAT PROCESS AND SO
THOSE ARE READILY OF IT THOUGH
THE LISTS ARE READILY AVAILABLE.
I MEAN I THINK IT'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT AND HOW MUCH
TIME HAVE TO HOSE I BY WHEN YOU
GO BACK TO THE VOTERS AND CHECK
WITH THEM TO SE IF. SINCE TEN
YEARS HAS GONE BY AND THINGS
HAVE CHANGED THAT THEY STILL
WANT THOSE EXACT SAME PROJECTS
FUNDED. WE DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CHANGE THAT LIST THAT
IS WHAT ONCE IT'S BEEN ADOPTED
BY THE VOTERS THAT IS WHAT THE
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS ARE. ALSO WE
HAVE BONDED AGAINST THOSE
DOLLARS AND SO WE HAVE
OBLIGATIONS WITH- WITH BOND
HOLDERS ON THOSE PROJECTS AS
WELL. FOR THE VERY SPECIFIC
PROJECT FOR INSTANCE HE- LANE
ADDING ON A HIGHWAY OR IS IT
MORE OPEN ENDED THAN THAT
CONGESTION RELIEF FOR INSTANCE I
SHOULD PROBABLY GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT I DON'T KNOW
SPECIFICALLY HOW IDENTIFIED TO
THE BOND HOUSE OKAY YEAH I'D BE
CURIOUS. TO FIND THAT OUT AS I'M
LEARNING. THIS ROLE SO THANK YOU
. SO YOU KNOW IT. THERE WAS A
TIME WHEN WE THOUGHT THAT IF
THERE WAS A FREEWAY THAT WAS
CONGESTED IF WE WOULD JUST ADD A
LANE ALL OF A SUDDEN IT WOULD-
INCREASING THE FLOW ABILITY OF
THE TRAFFIC CAN DECREASE
CONGESTION AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IS THAT
THAT'S USUALLY NOT THE CASE THAT
INSTEAD WHEN YOU HAD THE
CAPACITY TO. GET MORE DRIVERS
AND YOU GET YOU INVITE MORE
DRIVERS ON THE ROAD IN THE ROAD
BECOMES JUST AS IF NOT MORE
CONGESTED- AND WE SEE THE
IMPACTS OF DOING EXACTLY THAT
KIND OF WORK ON COMMUNITIES ON
AIR QUALITY AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
AND THE AUTHORS IS SPOT ON THAT
THERE IS A BETTER WAY. AND IT'S
A WAY THAT PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE SAID THAT THEY WANT WHICH
IS MORE MOBILITY OPTIONS- AND
LESS CONGESTION. SO I THINK THAT
THERE'S CERTAINLY A LOT TO WORK
OUT AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD-
YOU KNOW WE DO NEED TO LOOK AT
WHAT CALTRANS CURRENT PROCESSES
ARE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IS
THEY'VE BEEN PIVOTING AS AN
AGENCY. WE NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENS HOW YOU COUNT PROJECTS
THAT ARE EXPANDING BECAUSE
THEY'RE ADDING TRANSIT. OR
ADDING AN- OF A LANE FOR BUS
RAPID TRANSIT. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE LEAVE ROOM FOR OF
THE MARRIOTT OF VERY WELL
INTENDED PROJECTS. THAT COULD
INDEED HELP. A BUT I SUPPORT
YOUR GOALS WITH US AND SO I'M
GONNA SUPPORT MOVING FORWARD
TODAY. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE CONVERSATION CONTINUE
. THANK YOU- I'M COMMITTED TO
THAT AND- I DO AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO KEEP WORKING ON AND
APPRECIATE. EVERYONE'S
COMMITMENT TO COME TO THE TABLE
AND FIGURE SOMETHING OUT AND I'M
HOPEFUL ONCE I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU- DO YOU
HAVE A CLOSING STATEMENT OR IS
THAT IT. I WILL BE BRIEF THAT
THAT COULD BE. OKAY WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE'LL TAKE
THE BILL UP AS SOON AS WE HAVE
ONE MORE MEMBER. THANK YOU BOTH
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT I SEE AN AUTHORED
HERE. I DO MISTER GARCIA IS HERE
FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX
WELCOME. THE MANAGER MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE SPECTRALLY
REPRESENT REPRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY THIRTY SIX. THIS BILL
WOULD EXTEND THE AUTHORIZATION
FOR THE CARL MOYER PROGRAM TO
FIND A BROADER RANGE OF PROJECTS
THAT REDUCE EMISSIONS UNTIL
TWENTY THIRTY THREE. I WALKED
ARE GOING TO LOVE THE TO THE
ANALYSIS DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB
DESCRIBING. OUR EFFORT HERE AND
THERE WE HAVE TO WITNESSES.
RENDON TOLD LEGISLATOR ADVOCATE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS SECONDS
MATT. MISATO OKAY THANK YOU WHO
WERE WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES
APIECE YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BRENDAN TELLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTING THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER SMALL THIRTY FIVE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS AND DEDICATED TO
IMPROVING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PROVIDING CLEAN AIR FOR ALL OUR
RESIDENTS FOR PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AND STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD. OPERATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS ADMINISTER
THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL AND COST
EFFECTIVE CARL MOYER PROGRAM.
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CENTER PROGRAM- HAS AT RESULTED
OF- HAS ENABLED THE VOLUNTARY
REPLACEMENT SCRAPPAGE AND RE
POWER OF OVER SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND ENGINES RESULTING IN
REDUCTION OF MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND TONS
OF ITROGEN OXIDES AND REACTIVE
ORGANIC GASES. WHICH CONTRIBUTE
TO SMOG FORMATION AND ALSO THE
REDUCTION OF SEVENTY FIVE THREE
HUNDRED TONS OF PARTICULATE
MATTER MUCH OF WHICH IS DIESEL
EXHAUST AND AIR TOXIC- AIR
DISTRICTS ALSO ADMINISTER THE
COMPLEMENTARY EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
THREE LOCAL CLEAN AIR INCENTIVES
PROGRAM. WHICH PROVIDES
INCENTIVES OF FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
BUS FOR PLATE REPLACEMENTS
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLE SCRAPPING PROGRAMS
IN CARL MOYER QUALIFYING
PROJECTS RE AUTHORIZING THESE
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE EFFICIENT
EFFECTIVE IN PRIMARILY LOCALLY
OPERATED AND ADDRESS LOCAL
CONDITIONS AND PRIORITIES. IS
ESSENTIAL TO MEETING
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR GOALS
THEY ARE CRITICAL TO ATTAINING
BOTH HEALTH BASED NATIONAL AND
CALIFORNIA AMBIENT AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS AND FOR CUTTING
EMISSIONS OF DIESEL EXHAUST
PARTICULATE MATTER CARS TRUCKS
TRAINS. AND OTHER MOBILE
EQUIPMENT PRODUCE MORE THAN 70%
OF CALIFORNIA'S AIR POLLUTION
AND TO MEET FEDERAL CLEAN AND
STAY CLEAN AIR STANDARDS AND
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH THIS
PRODUCES POLLUTION MUST BE CUT
BY UP 280% BY THE TWENTY
THIRTIES. AB EIGHT SIX
REAUTHORIZES KEY FUNDING SOURCES
FOR CARL MOYER THE AB NINE
TWENTY THREE LOCAL INCENTIVES
PROGRAM AND THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THAT WILL ACCELERATE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AND IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE AND APPRECIATE YOU
LISTENING TO MY TESTIMONY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMMITTEE
STAFF I'M DOCTOR MET ME ASIDE OF
THE CHIEF TECHNOLOGIST AT THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WHICH IS THE
LARGEST AIR DISTRICT IN THE
NATION. WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX
AND PLEASED TO SERVE AS A CO
SPONSOR. AS YOU HEARD RENDON
MENTION THIS BILL WOULD
REAUTHORIZE CALIFORNIA'S MOST
SUCCESSFUL CLEANER PROGRAMS THE
CARL MOYER PROGRAM IN AB NINE
TWENTY THREE LOCAL SORT OF ERROR
PROGRAM. BOTH OF THESE ARE
CRITICAL FOR HELPING
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR GOALS AND
COLLECTIVELY REFERRED TO AS A
CARL MOYER PROGRAM. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
AIR EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS-
INCENTIVE PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
AND THEY ARE THE MODEL BY WHICH
OTHER REGIONS. A LOOK TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS THROUGH INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS. ARE THEY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN REDUCING EMISSIONS
FOR ALMOST A QUARTER CENTURY AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN COST
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING MOBILE
SOURCE EMISSIONS. AND BRENDAN
ALSO MENTION THE MOBILE SOURCES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS OFF ROAD
EQUIPMENT MARINE VESSELS.
LOCOMOTIVES THUS CONTRIBUTE 280%
OF THE EMISSIONS WITHIN THE
SOUTH COAST BASIN. SO THAT MEANS
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
RESIDENTS THAT ARE LIVING WITHIN
OUR REGION ARE BREATHING SOME OF
THE MOST UNHEALTHY AIR ANYWHERE
IN THE NATION. ESPECIALLY THOSE
LIVING IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN FACT THE SOUTH
COAST IS HOME 267% OF ALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THESE HARMFUL
MOBILE SOURCE EMISSIONS
EXACERBATE MANY HEALTH PROBLEMS
INCLUDING ASTHMA ATTACKS. HEART
DISEASE AND EVEN CERTAIN TYPES
OF CANCER. THESE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO
ASSIST IN THE PURCHASE OF
CLEANER THAN REQUIRED ENGINE AND
EQUIPMENT TECHNOLOGIES TO
ACHIEVE EMISSION REDUCTIONS THAT
ARE REAL SURPLUS QUANTIFIABLE
AND ENFORCEABLE. OVERALL THESE
PROGRAMS ARE WIDELY EMBRACED NOT
ONLY BY THE BREATHING PUBLIC BUT
ALSO BY INDUSTRY AND END USERS
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AHEAD OF ANY REGULATIONS. WE ARE
JUST REPORT FOR THIS AND BILL IN
ORDER CONTINUE. AIR DISTRICTS
CLEAN UP THE AIR IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ON FILE AT THIS TIME IS ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM. WOULD LIKE TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY SIX PLEASE COME UP.
DO SO NOW. DAVE THE CANTON OF
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS
VEHICLE COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TOM JORDAN WITH
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
DISTRICT A CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON RYAN
KENNY CLEAN ENERGY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. KRISH MOTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. CODY BOILS ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
WESTERN AG PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. REXTON BEHIND THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
AND THE NAP CHAPTERS CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALLEN
ABS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
CO SPONSOR OF TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM UP WISHING TO VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION.
SIGNAL MOVE FOR THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX. THANK
YOU A MILLION IN THE FOR YOUR IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THOUSAND ZERO. WHEN YOU GO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS WILL
PAIR UP WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ALSO SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF ASTHMA CARE
PROFESSIONALS PHYSICIANS AND
OTHER HEALTH MEDICAL
ORGANIZATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ON THE
OTHER LINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ALEXIS CHAVEZ ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
SUPPORT. WILL NOW GO TO LINE
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ANTHONY MILLION ON BACK TO THE
ON THE LINES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WELL NOT
QUITE A LINE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS COOK
BLACKBURN ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN STATES TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. AND
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO EIGHT THREE SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND YOUR PERSONALLY HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. YOU VERY MUCH LET'S
GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE. WAS THERE ONE MORE
PERSON WHO WANTED TO SPEAK. I
WILL ALLOW IT NOT. THE COMMAND
CHAIR TODD CAMPBELL REPRESENTING
THE BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE OKAY I THINK WE'VE
GOT EVERYONE- WAS HEARD ANYBODY
WANTED TO SPEAK. OKAY WE'LL GO
BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR CLOSING AYE
A CORAL MYERS BEEN AROUND FOR
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS- GETTING
SUCCESSFULLY GETTING DIESEL
TRUCKS OFF THE ROAD AND REPLACE
THE CLEANER OPTIONS THAT I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT YOUR- EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE THE PROGRAM SO I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
AND- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON
THIS MATTER RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. RIGHT WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM STILL- SO WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE WILL VOTE ON YOUR
LEGISLATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE SOUND
OF MY VOICE PLEASE COME DOWN SO
WE CAN GET A QUORUM AND START
PUTTING UP SOME OF THESE BILLS.
THANK YOU AND DO WE HAVE OUR
NEXT AUTHOR I SAW MISTER GRAY A
LITTLE WHILE AGO BUT HE- SEEMS
TO HAVE DISAPPEARED. DO WE HAVE
ANY- COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH
BILLS. EUROPE GO AHEAD MR LEE.
MR WE IF YOU ARE PREPARED OKAY.
OKAY ALREADY HAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH WE DRAFTING
COORDINATION WITH STAKEHOLDER
INPUT AND COMMITTEE FEEDBACKS
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
THIS BILL AB TWO TWO ZERO SIX
WILL AID IN THE ENFORCEMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S PARKING CASH OUT
PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN LW FOR
THE PAST THREE DECADES PARKING
CASH OUT PROGRAMS OR PCO FOR
SHORT REQUIRE CERTAIN EMPLOYERS
TO OFFER AN EQUAL BENEFITS
EMPLOYEES WHO DO NOT DRIVE TO
WORK AND THEREFORE DO NOT GET
THE BENEFITS OF FREE SUBSIDIZED
PARKING PROVIDE ABOUT EMPLOYER.
THE PROGRAM CREATES MORE EQUITY
TO THOSE WHO RIDE A BIKE OR TAKE
PUBLIC TRANSIT TO WORK TO
SUPPORT TRANSPORTATION METHODS
THAT REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT PCO IS NOT BEING
THE DIFFICULTY IN CALCULATING
THE VALUE OF EMPLOYEE PARKING
MANY OWNERS OF COMMERCIAL REAL
ESTATE BUNDLE THE COST OF
PARKING WITH THE COST OF AN
OFFICE SPACE INTO A SINGLE THESE
PRICE THIS PRACTICE MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR EMPLOYERS TO
SEPARATE THE COST OF PARKING
SPACES. IN ORDER US IS CONCERNED
AB TWENTY TWO OH SIX SIMPLY
REQUIRES A PRICE A PARKING TO BE
LISTED IN A COMMERCIAL LEASE IF
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE PCO
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA IS ONE
OF THE FEW JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THE SUCCESSFUL PCO
PROGRAM AND NOTES OF THE
UNBUNDLING OF PARKING IS A
USEFUL TOOL AND ITS
IMPLEMENTATION THE CITY HAS ITS-OWN UNBUNDLE PARKING PROVISION
TO MAKE IT EASIER TO IMPLEMENT
THE PCO PROGRAM. AFTER CLASS
YOUR SUPPORT TO HELP EASE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PEACE YOUR
PROGRAM AND TODAY I'LL BY PHONE
I WILL BE JOINED BY ALAN
GREENBERG- WAS EXPERT IN PARKING
CASH OUT POLICY AND FROM DC
WASHINGTON DC AND JOHN KASICH.
WHO IS TRANSPORTATION POLICY
MANAGER AT CBRE. THE YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATE CAN YOU PLEASE FIND
MISTER GREENBERG AYE MR KASS.
WERE AB TWENTY TWO OH SIX. YES
THE TICKET PLEASE PRESS STAR
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME SO WE CAN
OPEN YOUR LINE. IT JUST A MOMENT
A MYSTERY BURGER LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO OKAY
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE I'M HONORED TO
TESTIFIED TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO A SIX MANY CALIFORNIA'S
PARKING CASHEL TO SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVE IMPLEMENTATION. I WORKED
ON PARKING CASH OF FOR MANY
YEARS MOST RECENTLY SUPPORTING
PASSAGE OF WASHINGTON DC'S
TWENTY TWENTY ORDINANCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEASE AMENDMENTS
WOULD MAKE A HUGE IMPROVEMENT TO
THE CALIFORNIA LAW AND WILL
INCREASE ITS IMPACTS MANY FULL
WITHOUT BEING BURDENSOME TO ANY
PARTIES. WHEN ENACTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO CALIFORNIA'S
LAW WAS CONSIDERED
GROUNDBREAKING- IT REFLECTED AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE SOCIAL
ENGINEERING UNDERPINNING PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS PICKING ONLY COMMUTER
PARKING SUBSIDIZES COUNTRIES SO
MANY STATE CALLS. AND WHILE IT
WASN'T DESIGNED TO BE UNIVERSAL
IT WAS DESIGNED TO APPLY TO
EMPLOYERS- WHERE IT MATTERED
MOST IN AIR QUALITY NON
CONFORMING CONFORMANCE AREAS.
AND FROM PLAYERS LARGE ENOUGH TO
BE ABLE TO ADMINISTRATIVELY
HANDLE THE SMALL BURDENS OF
LEGISLATION. THE LAW THOUGH HAS
HISCHALLENGES MOST ESPECIALLY
THE- WHO THE VALUE OF CASH OUT
IS LINK NOT TO THE MARKET VALUE
BUT INSTEAD DUE OUT OF POCKET
COSTS. AND THAT IS BEEN REALLY
PROBLEMATIC SANTA MONICA FOR
EXAMPLE WHICH IS WHAT THE STATE
AND COMMUTER AND CASH AND- SO
THAT THREE QUARTERS OF EMPLOYERS
THAT SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO LAWS
HURT THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE OUT OF POCKET COSTS.
FOR THE PARKING THEY ARE FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEES. AND EVEN LEASES
- THAT DO A SEPARATELY PRICED
PARKING OFTEN DO SO AT A MUCH
REDUCED RATE AS AN INDUCEMENT
FOR EMPLOYERS TO ENTER LEASES.
WITH THE LEASING ENTITY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- LEASE
AMENDMENTS WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA
CONSISTENT WASHINGTON DC'S
ORGANS AND ALSO WITHOUT VIRUS
VALLEYS PARKING. SPECIFICALLY
THE IRS THE VALUE PARKING BASED
ON AN ARM'S LENGTH TRANSACTION.
AND EXCLUDE ANY CONSIDERATION OF
AN EMPLOYMENTRELATIONSHIP IN
DETERMINING THE VALUE THE
PARKING. AS AMENDED CALIFORNIA'S
LAW WOULD CONTINUE TO ALLOW
EMPLOYERS TO SET AND CHANGE
BENEFITS TO THEIR EMPLOYEES.
WITH ONE EXCEPTION AND THAT IS A
COULD NOT SOLELY OFFER PARKING
SUBSIDY TO THEIR EMPLOYEES.
LANDLORDS AND BUILDING OWNERS
ARE BURDENED BY NOTHING MORE
THAN JUST HONESTLY VALUING. THE
PARKING THAT THEY'RE MAKING
AVAILABLE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LISA
RENAMED FAITH EVEN TENTATIVELY
TO LAW BUT LIMITING ITS SCOPE TO
DEAL ONLY WITH WELL UNDERSTOOD
IMPLEMENTATION DIVISION
DEFICIENCIES IN OUR IF YOU CAN
FINISH UP PLEASE HERE YEAH. THE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE HUGELY
POSITIVE IN IMPACT IN THE C.
SUPPORT TO MRS YES PLEASE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OKAY CAN WE HAVE
THE NEXT WITNESS PLUS MY OTHER
WITNESSES UNAVAILABLE. OKAY
THANK YOU. WE THEN WILL GO TO
THE OPPONENTS ACTUALLY WILL DO
THE IN PERSON. TESTIMONY FOR
SELF IS ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF.
AB TWENTY TWO OH SIX THIS WILL
BE THE TIME OR HAVE YOU READY
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAH ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND HAS
BEEN NOTED WE ARE CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM. LIKE
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
THIS MEASURE ME LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDMENTS. ARE THE
COMMITMENTS AND PRINT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOU. ALLEN ABS WITH
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT OKAY LET'S GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE'RE
GONNA START WITH REX TIME. I LET
ME MAKE SURE YOUR MIKE IS ON IT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT IS ABOUT
NOW MARIA. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS REX W. HÌNH
WITH CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION- OUR
MEMBERS JUST HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF HEARTBURN IN REGARDS TO
GETTING INVOLVED IN BUSINESS
BEEN WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN HIS OFFICE. VERY WELL
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE TIME AND
CONVERSATIONS HAD BEEN PUT IN WE
ARE ALL FOR FIGURING OUT THIS
PARKING CASH OUT PROGRAM AND WE
BELIEVE WE CAN GET TO A SPOT
WHERE WE DO THAT WITH THE BEST
POLICY AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S MOVE
NOW TO ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO IS
IN OPPOSITION TO THE LEGISLATION
CAN CLIP TO MICROPHONE. OKAY SEE
NONE. OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO OH
SIX. THANK YOU ONE CAN LATE IN
GENERAL IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY TWO OH SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. BY YOUR LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
EDDIE GOT A MEDAL- ON BEHALF OF
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ACTION FUND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB HERE TWO TWO ZERO
SIX THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO OH SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ENSURE PERSON AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL GO TO THE COMMITTEE
NOW. THE COMMITTEE MEMBER
WISHING TO OPINE OR QUESTION. IF
THANK YOU ON QUESTION FOR YOU.
RIGHT NOW OBVIOUSLY WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES REALLY NOT FEELING
THAT THEY HAD OVER COALBED IN
TRYING TO STAY AFLOAT WITH
EXCESSIVE REGULATIONS AND FEES
WENT THIS PRETTY MUCH HAVE A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER THAT HAS
MORE THAN FIFTY EMPLOYEES THINK
ABOUT JUST NOT OFFERING FREE
PARKING ALTOGETHER THAT COULD
THEN AFFECT THOSE THAT PERHAPS
DUE HAVE TO DROUGHT YOU KNOW
DRIVE AWAIT YOU TRAVEL FROM SAY
RIVERSIDE TO ORANGE COUNTY OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. WHEN THAT
HAVE THE OPPOSITE EFFECT IN IN
HELPING THEM SO IN THE PARKING
CASH OUT PROGRAM WHICH IS
EXISTING LAW ALREADY YOU KNOW
THE THIS BILL ONLY SEEKS TO
CLARIFY TO AND UNBUNDLE IT SO
BASICALLY IF A SMALL BUSINESSES
WHICH HAS A PARKING LOT THAT
THEIR- LEASING WITH THE BILLING
THE CITY FOR THE BUSINESS
THEY'RE ALREADY PAYING FOR THE
PARKING IT'S NOW THAT A BUSINESS
CAN GET THE CLARITY OF WELL HOW
MUCH IS A PARKING AFTER COSTA
SEIFERT RIGHT BECAUSE YOU'RE
PAYING FOR THE PARKING LOT. AND
THE STRUCTURE NOW SAYING WELL
HE'S OFF STRUCTURE HERE'S OUR
PARKING AND THAT'S JUST CLARITY
FOR YOU IT'S AN OR AS AN
EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYEES SO
THIS DOESN'T CREATE ANYTHING NEW
JUST GIVING MORE TRANSPARENCY TO
BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYEES SO IT'S
NOT GONNA BE ANY EXTRA COST TO
THE- EMPLOYEE. NO. EMPLOYERS TO
SPEAK NOW OKAY THANK YOU. WELL
THE HOPE IS WE HAVE TRANSPARENCY
WHEN GET MORE EXTRA DOLLARS INTO
THE EMPLOYEE. POSSIBLE EMPLOYEES
POCKET IF THEY SO CHOOSE NOT TO
DRIVE ANYMORE. THANK YOU MISTER
WARD. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE ON
THE AUTHOR BRING THIS FOR AS WE
INTEND TO DISCUSS WILL BRIEFLY
BEFORE THIS I KNOW THERE'S GONNA
BE SOME. CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE IT
MIGHT BE DIFFICULT TO ACTUALLY-
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT WHAT THAT
COST SHARE MIGHT BE-
PARTICULARLY I THINK IN A IN A
LESS URBANIZED ENVIRONMENT
WHERE. I'M WORKING MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT MORE AMPLE- COULD BE
AVAILABLE TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC-
AS WELL THE EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
THERE SO IT'S REALLY TOUGH I
THINK SOMETIMES AND BE ABLE TO
TEASE OUT OUT- ENCOURAGED THERE
MIGHT BE EXISTING FORMULA THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT. ELSEWHERE IN
THE COUNTRY THAT- PARTICULAR
BEHIND THIS TO IRIS ON
APPROPRIATION OF THOSE SOME OF
THOSE FACTORS THAT THAT. COULD
BE SOMETHING TO UNDERSTAND AND-
YOU KNOW I'VE ALSO ENCOURAGED
YOU'RE- WORKING WITH SOME OF
THE- THE BUSINESS PROPERTIES AS
HE'S IN SOME OF THE OTHER
OPPONENTS AS WELL TO BE ABLE TO
TRY TO WORK TOGETHER O FIGURE
OUT. WHAT THAT WHAT THAT COULD
BE- VERY MUCH SUPPORT OF THE
PARKING CASH OUT PROGRAM AS WELL
NOT PARTICULARLY THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE THE- SHIFT
TOWARDS ALTERNATIVES AND FOR
PEOPLE TO HAVE THAT CHOICE- BUT-
IT'S TRICKY AT THE MOMENT TO BE
ABLE TO SEE HOW. THAT COULD BE
ASCRIBED TO EVERY- OFFICER EVERY
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY- THAT IS OUT
THERE ACROSS THE STATE- BECAUSE
THE LANDSCAPE CAN BE DIFFERENT
AND IN CERTAIN AREAS AS WELL. I
KNOW CERTAINLY FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS IS WE'RE LOOKING TO
CLOSE RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION.
THE ABILITY TO UNBUNDLE- THOSE
CLASSES WELL AND GIVE CHOICE- TO
THE PERSPECTIVE- LET'S SEE OR
THE PERSPECTIVE- OWNER. OF THAT
PROPERTY AS WELL- SO ENGINEERING
THAT SORT OF AFTER THE FACT-
CANCEL TURKEY. SUPPORTS DAY
GOING FOR PAYING PROJECT. TRY TO
FIGURE OUT THIS ISN'T REALLY A
FAIR APPORTIONMENT- AS ARE
TRYING TO APPLY THE EXISTING
PROGRAM SORT OF RETROSPECTIVELY
TO THESE- ARE. ALREADY BUILT
FACILITIES. THANK EVEN ELSE.
OKAY MISTER LEVY I APPRECIATE
YOUR TRYING TO MAKE THE SET OF
PROGRAM WORK BETTER THAN IT DOES
NOW I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS AND I KNOW THAT THE
OPPOSITIONCAME IN A LITTLE BIT
ON THE LATE SIDE NIGHT PRESS
THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM AND TRY TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS AS WELL 'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY I'M
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE BUT
WHEN THE TIME COMES BUT YOU KNOW
THAT SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
IT'S INCREASING THE TRANSPARENCY
UNBUNDLING OF PARKING IS ONE THE
NECESSARY TOOLS ENSURE THAT PCO
SUCCESS ONE IF WE DON'T
UNBUNDLING GIVE TRANSPARENCY TO
EMPLOYERS AND BETWEEN CONTRACTS
WE ARE GONNA HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
PCO PROGRAM WHICH IS WHY IT'S
KIND OF LANGUAGE IN THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS SO STRICTLY ANSWER
AYE BUT WHEN THE TIME COMES
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER LISTEN
AS WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL WILL.
YOU WANT ME TO. MY OTHER. ON WE
HAVE AUTHORS HERE NOW SO IT'S A
GOOD. BUT WORKING. I CAN FOLLOW.
OKAY SO NEXT WE HAVE MISTER
SALAS WELCOME. MISTER SALAS
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE FOR A
BILL THAT IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT
BILL WHICH PASSED UNANIMOUSLY
LAST YEAR. THAT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED PERCENT AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY THREE TODAY
WHICH IS THE REINTRODUCTION OF
AB TEN THIRTY FIVE FROM LAST
YEAR. WHICH IS COMMITTEE PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY AS YOU STATED IN
PRETTY MUCH UNANIMOUSLY THROUGH
THE ENTIRE PROCESS THIS BILL
JUST DEALS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE I DO HAVE TESTIMONY
HERE IN SUPPORT. I DO HAVE-
MISTER CHARLIE RAY DIRECTOR OF
SAFETY AND TECHNICAL SERVICES
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION
AND INDUSTRIAL MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU YOUR
WITNESS PLEASE. ALRIGHT WELL YOU
I'M SORRY MISTER REAGAN TO PUSH
THE BUTTON SO. CHARLIE RIGHT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRIAL MATERIALS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT A CALCIUM IS MADE UP
pCOMPANIES COMPANIES THAT PRODUCE
ROCKS AND GRAVEL CONCRETE
ASPHALT THAT HELP BUILD OUR
ROADS BRIDGES RAIL TRANSIT AND
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE. RECYCLING
OF CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS
CONSERVE NATURAL RESOURCES OF
AGGREGATES TO PRESERVE THE BODY
ENERGY OF CEMENT CONCRETE OIL
ASPHALT REDUCES GREENHOUSE GASES
AND KEEPS MATERIALS OUT OF
LANDFILLS. THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE FROM
LAST YEAR'S AB ONE ZERO THREE
FIVE THIS VERSION COMPLETELY
EXAM CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE
LOWEST QUARTILE. REVENUE
ACCORDING TO THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND THE FINANCIAL DATA. AND LIKE
THEM SAYS IT WOULD NOT REQUIRE
ANY CITY OR COUNTY TO USE
RECYCLED MATERIALS WHERE IT'S
NOT AVAILABLE ARTS IT'S TOO
COSTLY. THE USE OF RECYCLED
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS A SOUND
COST EFFECTIVE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE AND
SHOULD BE PRACTICED BY ALL STATE
FUNDED ENTITIES HELPING TO BUILD
OUR STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION ON FILE AS OR
ANYBODY HERE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN THE
ROOM. SO PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE IF ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. I'M SORRY WE DIDN'T WE DO
HAVE AN OFFICE IN OPPOSITION
WITNESS I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT SO
SIR. I BEG YOUR PARDON PLEASE
COME ON UP YOUR TWO MINUTES. I
DIDN'T KNOW WHO WAS GOING TO BE
SPEAKING SESSIONS HAVE YOU COULD
INTRODUCE YOURSELF PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND- STAFFA DAMON
CONKLIN WITH THE LEGAL
CALIFORNIA CITIES- WE ACTUALLY
JUST MET WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS THIS LAST FRIDAY TO
DISCUSS THE BILL- WE'RE GOING TO
RECOUNT ARE OPPOSING. IT AND
MAKE IT OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED-
WE DIDN'T HAVE A HAND IN A
LEARNING SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
THAT WAS- RECENTLY AMENDED IN
THE BILL- SPECIFICALLY TO THE
REVENUE TRIGGERING THIS BUT WE-
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE STAKE HOLDERS
AND- FINDING A PATHWAY TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. YEP. OKAY
SORRY ABOUT THAT THIS ROOM STILL
HAS THE NEW ROOM SMELL AND WE'RE
STILL GETTING USED TO IT SO IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL OKAY SEEING NINE
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY THREE. THANK
YOU. AND LAYS GENERAL'S YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THAT'S ONE ZERO FUTURE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
NINE FIVE THREE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE FOR OUR FIRST
PARTY.
WE SHOULD PATIENTS BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT. BORDERLINE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
BRIAN DATA REPRESENT GRANITE
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY- CALLING IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. NEXT TO A
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU THIS IS JOHN
HALVORSEN WITH NATIONAL READY
MIXED CONCRETE COMPANY IN FAVOR. WELL NOT A LINE NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS PEGGY ROBERTSON I'M WITH
HOLIDAY ROCK AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND ONCE
AGAIN LAYS JUNKYARD SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NUMBER
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SORRY I ALREADY VOTED IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. THANKS TO
JOHN AT NATIONAL RATE NEXT. MY
MISTAKE NO WORRIES. ENSURE
PERSON AT THIS TIME I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU WILL GO
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE DOES
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WELL THIS IS ONE TO
GET A GOOD BILL MADE EVEN BETTER
HOPEFULLY WILL NOW BE VETO PROOF
BUT TRYING TO GET A HANDLE ON
THE- I'M- FUNDS OF A CONCRETE-
AND- ALL OF THE THAT COULD. BE
DIVERTED FROM OUR WE STREAMS AND
GO BACK INTO OUR ROADS IS
REALLY. WONDERFUL WORK AND I'M
GLAD THAT YOU'RE TAKING IT ON
AGAIN THANK YOU HOLDING THE BILL
TODAY. WE STILL DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM SO SOON AS WE DO WE WILL
TAKE A VOTE ON YOUR BILL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL WHEN THE TIMES
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SALAS. I SEE MR
GREY. PERFECTLY TIMED FOR AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO YOU CAN
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
I'M CHAIR MEMBERS. AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY TWO ADDRESSES
SKYROCKETING SKYROCKETING RATES
OF CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFT BY
REQUIRING THAT CAR DEALERS
PERMANENTLY MARK CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS WITH THE VIN OF THE
VEHICLE TO WHICH THEY'RE
ATTACHED CRIMINALIZING THE
TAMPERING OR REMOVAL OF THE VAN
MARKING AND REQUIRING SMOG
CHECKS TO INCLUDE A NOTIFICATION
TO DRIVERS ABOUT WHETHER THEIR
CATALYTIC CONVERTER HAS BEEN
MARKED. HELLO CONVERTERS ARE
COMPOSED OF A VEHICLE'S EXHAUST
SYSTEM THAT REDUCE HARMFUL. AIR
EMISSIONS BY CONVERTING
HYDROCARBONS AND CARBON MONOXIDE
INTO WATER VAPOR AND CARBON
DIOXIDE IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
CONTAIN PRECIOUS METALS LIKE
PALLADIUM RHODIUM AND PLATINUM.
WELL CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFT
IS NOTHING NEW. RECENT SPIKES IN
THE VALUE OF PARTIALS METALS-
TRAXXAS SPIKE IN THEFTS FOR
EXAMPLE FIVE YEARS AGO AN OUNCE
OF RHODIUM COST A HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS BUT NOW SELLS FOR
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS. OVER THAT SAME PERIOD
CATHOLIC CONVERTED TESTS OF
INCREASED MORE THAN TENFOLD IN
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION
ACCOUNTING FOR MORE THAN 30% OF
ALL CLAIMS FILED WITH STATE FARM
. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE US
RECORD THIRTEEN HUNDRED KELLER
CONVERTED STAFF BY TWENTY TWENTY
THE NUMBER WAS FOURTEEN THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE.
AND DATA FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE
INDICATES THE NUMBER MORE THAN
DOUBLED TO THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
STAFFS STAFFS JUST REPORTED. BY
STATE FARM CUSTOMERS. HIGH
PRICES FOR THE PRECIOUS METAL'S
FOUNDING CATHOLIC CONVERTERS ARE
EXPECTED TO CONTINUE DUE TO
SUPPLY DISRUPTIONS CAUSED BY THE
RUSSIAN INVASION OF UKRAINE.
WITH RUSSIA PRODUCING ALMOST 40%
OF THE WORLD'S MIND PALLADIUM.
SO LONG AS THIS FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE EXISTS WE SHOULD
EXPECT TO SEE THEFTS CONTINUE
WHILE VEHICLES MOST OFTEN HIT BY
THIEVES INCLUDE S. U. V.'S AND
FLEET VEHICLES- WITH HIGH GROUND
CLEARANCE- AS WELL AS TOYOTA
PRIUS IS. ANY VEHICLE CAN BE
TARGETED WHAT STOLEN THIEVES-
TYPICALLY FLIP CATHOLIC
CONVERTERS FOR FIFTY TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. WHILE VICTIMS
CAN EXPECT TO PAY ANYWHERE FROM
ONE THOUSAND TO FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO GET THE VEHICLE
FIXED. UNLESS THE THIEF IS
CAUGHT IN THE ACT RED HANDED LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS FEW TOOLS TO
INVESTIGATE THIS CRIME AS IT IS
DIFFICULT TO LINK AN INDIVIDUAL
WITH ANY SPECIFIC STOLEN
CATALYTIC CONVERTER. AS A RESULT
EVEN WHEN A SUSPECT IS ARRESTED
MANY ARE NEVER PROSECUTED.
CONSISTENT WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
UNDER AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
MARKING A CATALYTIC CONVERTER
WITH THE VEHICLES VAN IS A BEST
PRACTICE RECOMMENDED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY. AS WELL AS THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR.
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFTS ARE
CRIMES OF OPPORTUNITY WITH
THIEVES TARGETING VEHICLES AND
LOW RISK ENVIRONMENTS WE HAVE
THE GREATEST EASE OF ACCESS.
ONCE REMOVED AWAY FROM THE CRIME
SCENE THERE ARE FEW
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO RECOVER OR TRACE
A STOLEN CONVERTER. UNDER AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO ATTACHED
CATALYTIC CONVERTER CAN BE
EASILY TRACED BACK TO ITS
ORIINAL VEHICLE AND LEGAL
OWNERSHIP CAN BE ESTABLISHED. IF
THE MARKING ON THE CONVERSION
MOVED IN POSSESSION OF THAT
CONVERTERS A CRIME WHICH WILL
SERVE AS A SIGNIFICANT DETERRENT
FOR ANY BLACK MARKET REPAIR SHOP
OR RECYCLER TO TAKE POSSESSION
OF THE STOLEN PART. FURTHER MANY
DRIVERS ARE UNAWARE OF THE RISK.
OF THEFT UNTIL IT HAPPENS AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO REQUIRES
SMOG CHECK STATIONS TO SIMPLY
NOTIFY DRIVERS IF THEIR
CATALYTIC CONVERTER IS MARKED.
THIS NOTIFICATION WILL PROB
DRIVERS TO CONSIDER VOLUNTARILY
HAVING THEIR- CALIBURGER MARKED
A TRACEABLE MANNER. NEARLY A
DOZEN BILLS HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED
IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR TO
ADDRESS THIS STAFFED. AB TWENTY
SIX A TWO IS ONE OF THE FEW WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK MY CO AUTHORS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI AND PATTERSON FOR
THEIR SUPPORT. I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY TWO REMAINS A WORK IN
PROGRESS. LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND SHARING THIS
MARKING RECORD REQUIREMENT IS
SUFFICIENTLY NARROW. FOR
EXAMPLE. THE CAR DEALERS WHO
PROVIDE COMPELLING INFORMATION
THAT HIGHLIGHTS VARIOUS
EXHAUSTED SIGNS SOME OF WHICH
VERY THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER
DEEP INSIDE THE VEHICLE.
REQUIRING DEALERS TO MARK- A
CONVERTER WITH THIS DESIGN IS
IMPRACTICAL AS THEY WOULD HAVE
TO DISASSEMBLE. MAJOR ENGINE
COMPONENTS IN ORDER TO ACCESS
THAT PART. FORGERY THE SAME
DESIGN ALSO MARK MAKES A SET
ACCEPTING. FOR THE DEEP
DIFFICULT AND- THOSE VEHICLES
USUALLY WILL NOT BE TARGETED.
ANOTHER CONCERN RAISED HIS
REPLACES REQUIREMENTS SALVAGE
POOLS ARE VEHICLES HEADED TO
DISMANTLE OURS NEITHER OF THESE
EXAMPLES ARE THE TARGET OF THE
BILL. I WANT TO THANK THE
OPPOSITION FOR ENGAGING IN
PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE IN A FIRM
THAT I AM COMMITTED TO TAKING
FUTUREAMENDMENTS- THAT ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS. AB TWENTY SIX A
TWO IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION TRIPLE
A THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION AND VALLEY CLEAN AIR
NOW- MADAM CHAIR ON THE PHONE-
THIS AFTERNOON I'M JOINED BY
MERCED COUNTY SHERIFF VERN
WARNKE HE WHO IS ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE. A SOME TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE FIND THE WITNESS MR-
MISTER ONE K. SHERIFF WHERE QUE
SORRY. YES MISS WHY THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MANAGER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND ADAM THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- AFRICAN CHAMPION THIS BILL
AS THE SHERIFF OF A WORLD COUNTY
I AM OFTEN ALLED BY SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY THAT-
SUPPORT. ALL EFFORTS TO GET THAT
IN A- HANDLED THE SITUATION AS
BEST I CAN SAID BE THE FOLKS I'M
DEALING WITH THE GOVERNMENT A-
SOME BUSINESSES TRACTOR
OPERATORS AND SO ONE THAT HAVE
BEEN HIT MULTIPLE TIMES ON THE
SAME VEHICLES AFTER THEY'VE
SPENT THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
GETTING THESE VEHICLES REPAIRED.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT'S GETTING
HURT BY THIS IS THE ACTUAL
VEHICLE OWNERS YOU SEE THE
MUFFLER SHOPS THE- PARTS
DEPARTMENT SAID WE THAT ARE
SELLING THE THINGS AND IN THE
CELL BLOCK THAT ARE SELLING THE
PRECIOUS METALS THESE ARE ALL
PEOPLE THAT ARE GAINING PERMITS.
AND AT THE EXPENSE AND COST OF.
THE CONSUMER WHICH IS OWNING THE
AUTOMOBILE USED CARS HAVE THE
RANGE LIKE IT WAS FOR HEARD FROM
ONE THOUSAND TO FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN REPAIRS AND YET- WE
CAN FIND PROTECTION. IN
MULTITUDES WHERE IT'S STILL
CONSIDERED A MISS AMERICA I
WOULD STILL LIKE TO HAVE THIS AS
A FELONY WILL NOT A WOBBLER
BECAUSE IT COSTS THE CONSUMER
WELL OVER THE NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR THRESHOLD SO I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS AND AGAIN- ADAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CHAMPION S. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE A- IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF. OF AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO. OKAY
SEEING NONE WE DO HAVE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IF THEY'RE
HERE IN THE ROOM IF THEY CAN
PLEASE COME UP TO THE TABLE. AND
BE SURE YOU PUSH THE BUTTONS AND
THEN YOU CAN INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ANTHONY SAMPSON THE SAMPSON
ADVISERS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION. TNC DA'S TAKEN AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO. I AM
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE
IN A DIALOGUE WITH US REGARDING
OUR CONCERNS. OF FIRST ASEAN CDA
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE UNDERLYING
INTENT OF THE BILL INTO THIS AND
IS CURRENTLY IN SUPPORT. OF
SEVERAL OTHER CATALYTIC
CONVERSION. A CONVERTER
MEASURES. I INTRODUCED ABOUT THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE. AS IT
RELATES TO THIS BILL. THE
INSIDIOUS CONCERNS RELATE
SPECIFICALLY TO THE REQUIREMENT
THE DEALERSHIPS PERMANENTLY
MARK. OR ETCH THE VIN NUMBER
INTO THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER
BEFORE. THE VEHICLE COULD BE
SOLD. BUT AT THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAY. POINTS OUT MANY VEHICLE
MODELS INCORPORATE THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER IS PART OF THE EXHAUST
MANIFOLD. REQUIRING DEALERSHIP
TECHNICIANS TO DISASSEMBLE A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION. OF THE
VEHICLE ENGINE JUST TO ACCESS
THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER. AND
JUST TO PROVIDE TWO EXAMPLES TO
PERMANENTLY MARK ONE VOLVO MODEL
IT WOULD TAKE A DEALERSHIP
TECHNICIAN TWO POINT EIGHT TO
FOUR HOURS. THE PERMANENTLY MARK
ONE VEHICLE DEPENDING ON ENGINE
VARIANTS. FOR CERTAIN ACURA
MODELS IT CAN TAKE TWO TO FIVE
HOURS. BUT EVEN ASSUMING A
PERMANENTLY MARKING VIN NUMBERS
INTO CATALYTIC CONVERTERS WAS
SIMPLE AND INEXPENSIVE. WE WOULD
NOTE FOR THE COMMITTEE THAT MANY
OF THE MOST TARGETED VEHICLES
ARE NOT EVEN BEING SOLD BY NEW
CAR DEALERSHIPS. DATA FROM THE
SERVICE DEPARTMENT OF ONE LARGE
TOYOTA DEALERSHIP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHOWS THAT THE MOST
TARGETED VEHICLES ARE
200-062-0009 PRIUS IS. WHICH
VERY FEW NEW CAR DEALERS EVEN
SELL. RATHER THOSE ARE OFTEN
SOLD THROUGH PRIVATE VENDORS
LIKE RECKLESS. EBAY MOTORS AND
FACEBOOK MARKET PLACE WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US A
MORE TARGETED IN STREAMLINED
SOLUTION WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THAT CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR
DEALERSHIPS ARE NOT SADDLED WITH
THE LABOR INTENSIVE AND COSTLY
OBLIGATION OF PERMANENTLY
MARKING EVERY VEHICLE THAT THEY
SELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION THE TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR THE AUTOMAKERS- YOU KNOW
CONSISTENT WITH WITH MY
COLLEAGUE- WE BELIEVE THE BILL
IS BOTH OVER OVERLY BROAD AN
OVERLY NARROW- OVERLY BROAD IN
ITS APPLICATION ALL VEHICLES
THAT GO THROUGH THESE VARIOUS
SYSTEMS AS MISTER SAMPSON NOTED
NOT EVERY VEHICLE IS PRONE TO
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFT AND SO
WE APPRECIATE THE- THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENTS ABOUT. WORKING TO
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL IN
ADDITION WE THINK THE BILL IS
OVERLY NARROW IN FACT IN THE
FACT THAT IT IT PRESCRIBES ONE
SOLUTION AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT. BAR
ACTUALLY- SUGGESTED A COUPLE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT CONSUMERS
COULD DO- MOTION SENSOR ALARMS
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS AND IN MANY CASES
MIGHT BE LESS EXPENSIVE OPTIONS
TO THE CONSUMER. TO ACTUALLY. BE
A DETERRENT AND A PREVENTATIVE
MEASURE. WITH RESPECT TO
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFT VERSES
VERSES THE VAN EIGHT YOU KNOW
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE SEE VERY
LITTLE EVIDENCE- IF ANY EXISTS
THAT HAVING A VAN ON THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER IS ACTUALLY
A DETERRENT TO THEFT WHEREAS.
OTHER MEASURES UP COULD BE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR FOLKS TO
ACCESS THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER
IN A QUICK WAY. UNNOTICED AND
UNSEEN BY OTHERS IN THE AREA AND
SO WE THINK THAT- EXPLORING
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS WITH RESPECT
TO PROTECTIVE AND PREVENTIVE
MEASURES IS A IS A WORTHWHILE
DISCUSSION TO HAVE IS THE BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WAS OR ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU AT LEAST
GENERAL MANAGEMENT IF YOU WERE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB TWO
SIX EIGHT TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. GOING TO
GO TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN
DOWN STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. MEXICO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRIN MEMBERS ANY GOVERNMENTAL
ON BEHALF OF VALLEY CLEAN AIR
NOW IN SUPPORT. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO LIE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
ALLISON EIGHTY ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN LAYS GENEROUS
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ENSURE PERSONALLY HAVE NO ONE
IN Q. THANK YOU WILL GO BACK TO
THE OF WERE YOU WANTING TO SPEAK
I WAS JUST HOPING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF OKAY IF YOU CAN GO
AHEAD. REAL QUICK EXIT YOUR MALL
. EXAGRID MALTESE WITH TRIPLE H.
AS HERE IN SUPPORT SORRY FOR THE
DELAY I'M A LITTLE RUSTY
APPARENTLY THAT'S OKAY WE'RE ALL
CATCHING UP HERE. OKAY ANYBODY
ELSE ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYBODY HAS
ANY COMMENTS. QUESTIONS MISTER
NAZARIAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WHEN THE TIME COMES I'D BE HAPPY
TO MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK TO ALSO BE
ADDED AS A- CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU SO AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR WE HAD PROBABLY A
DOZEN CATALYTIC CONVERTER BILLS.
SUBMITTED TO US THIS IS SUCH A
HUGE PROBLEM ACROSS THE STATE WE
HEARD FROM PEOPLE ALL THE TIME
I. ACTUALLY HAD TO SPEND FORTY
DOLLARS BY CATALYTIC CONVERTER
CAGE FROM MY PREVIOUS. AND IT
WORKS WITH THE CARS NEVER DRIVEN
THE SAME. SO THIS IS CERTAINLY A
PROBLEM IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND-
IN MANY OTHERS AND YOURS IS THE
LAST BILL STANDING YEARS WAS THE
ONE THAT REALLY MADE THE MOST
SENSE. AND SEEMED LIKE THE
REALLY THE WAY TO GO FORWARD SO
I COMMEND YOU FOR WORKING SO
HARD ON THIS A TAKING ON AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC AND FOR WORKING
SO WELL WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
MY STAFF ON AMENDMENTS. AND I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH. OF
THE OPPONENTS- AND TRY TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS SO AGAIN
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS. AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO HAVE ME. AND
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM AS SOON
AS WE DO WE WILL- TAKE A VOTE ON
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SORRY.
JUST THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WELCOME THE
ADDITIONAL CO AUTHORS AND-
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF YOUR
STAFF AND THE WORK RELATIONSHIP
AND- THANK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. MR TANG YOUR UP AND
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY YOU CAN
PROCEED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- PRESENTING AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN WHICH REQUIRES
THAT CARP REDESIGN ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS TO
WARD. PAYMENTS TO FOCUS MORE IN
INCOME AND ALSO USAGE OF
GASOLINE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF INCENTIVE PROGRAMS I'M
A BIG FAN OF MANY OF THEM.
HOWEVER THE NOT THEY AREN'T
TARGETING PEOPLE BASED ON HOW
MUCH GASOLINE THE USE WE THINK
THAT- BY TARGETING LARGER USERS
AND HAVING A LARGER IN CENTER
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE USING- MORE
GASOLINE LONGER COMMUTES ARE
SUPER COMMUTERS SUPER USERS- WE
REALLY FEEL LIKE INSTEAD OF
WOULD BE. PUT TO BETTER USE I
HAVE ONE- ONE SPONSOR FROM
CULTURE HERE TO TESTIFY. BUT WE
THINK THAT AFTER MANY YEARS IT'S
TIME FOR A NEW LOOK AT THESE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS TO REALLY
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
TARGETING OUR DOLLARS AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL GO TO YOUR
WITNESS TWO MINUTES PLEASE YEAH
. NONPROFIT DEDICATED. IT'S A
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. THE
FACTORS CREATE THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL A FIRST LOWER INCOME
DRIVERS WHO ARE USING THE MOST
GASOLINE ARE SPENDING OFTEN A
QUARTER OR MORE OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLD INCOME ON GASOLINE.
AND SECOND BURNING GASOLINE AND
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES IS THE
SINGLE BIGGEST SOURCE OF CARBON
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
THERE PROGRAMS ARE NOT- TAKING
CALIFORNIA'S GASOLINE USE DOWN
WERE HOLDING STEADY AT FIFTEEN
BILLION GALLONS A YEAR AND WE
HAVE BEEN FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS. AND THEN THIRD DESERVE
MARKET IS NOW MATURE RATIONALLY
HAVING IS AB SHORTAGE OF THESE
THREE THINGS GASOLINE BURDEN
FAMILIES THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND
THE ZIP SHORTAGE REQUIRED THAT
WE REFORM IS AB INCENTIVES WE
DON'T NEED TO KEEP INCENTIVISING
SELVES FOR WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T BURNING VERY MUCH
GASOLINE- WE DO NEED TO MAXIMIZE
EMISSIONS CUTS BY GETTING THE
DRIVERS WHO ARE USING THE MOST
GASOLINE TO SWITCHED HIS ABS.
AND W DO NEED TO MAXIMIZE
EQUITY BY- EXPEDITING THE
SWITCHES ABS FOR THE LOWER
INCOME DRIVERS WHO ARE USING THE
MOST GASOLINE. AND WE DO NEED TO
ENSURE THAT ARE SCARCE SUPPLY
THEMSELVES IS GOING TO THE
BIGGEST USERS OF GASOLINE- AND
DISPLACING THE MOST GHASTLY
IMPOSSIBLE THE THINK ABOUT IT
THIS WAY IF THE BIGGEST GASOLINE
USERS WERE TO SWITCH FIRST IT
WOULD TAKE NINE MILLION SALES ON
THE ROAD TO CUT OUR VEHICLE
EMISSIONS IN HALF. IF THE
BIGGEST GASOLINE USER SWITCHED
LAST AS THEY'RE CURRENTLY ON
TRACK TO DO IT'LL TAKE TWENTY
FOUR MILLION ZAB ON THE ROAD
NEARLY THREE TIMES AS MUCH.
ABOUT WAIT THERE'S MORE
INCENTIVE INCENTIVIZING THE
BIGGEST GASOLINE USERS TO SWITCH
TO CELEBS. WOULD ADDITIONALLY
SAVE THEM UP TO AROUND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH ON FUEL
AND MAINTENANCE. THAT MONEY IS
NOT EVEN COMING FROM THE
GOVERNMENT- AND THAT COULD BE AN
ADDED BENEFIT FOR THEM OFTEN
HELPING THEM TO MAKE THERE'S AB
OTHER PAYMENTS ON THERE'S A- THE
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN SIMPLY
ENSURES. THAT SEVEN SENATORS
MAXIMIZE EMISSIONS CUTS UP FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED IT THE MOST
SO I URGE THAT YOU PLEASE VOTE
AYE ON AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
DO HAVE ONE OPPOSITION WITNESS
BEFORE WE GO TO THAT WITNESSES
OR ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN PERSON. IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. OKAY SEEING NONE.
WE DO HAVE- SOMEONE FROM THE BAY
AREA QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. REGISTERED HIS
OPPOSITION ARE THEY HERE. JUST
IN CASE OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN
THE PHONE LINES AND SEE IF THERE
IS IN OUR A REGISTERED WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION FROM THE BAY AREA
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT FOR
THE BILL. FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN. AND IF YOU ARE COULD
YOU PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I DON'T SHOW ANYBODY
QUEUING UP FOR THAT OKAY. AS
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. ASING NONE WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE PHONE LINES TO OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY EIGHTEEN AT. TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN. THANK YOU
FAMILIES IN GENERAL IF YOU DO
WANT TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIXTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN. ENSURE PERSON I HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. OKAY LET'S TAKE IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY YES MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU. I GET THE
CONCEPT OF SWITCHING TO IF YOUR
GOALS REDUCE EMISSIONS IT SEEMS
LIKE INCENTIVIZING PEOPLE THAT
DRIVE THE MOST. CONSUME THE MOST
GAS. IS AN EFFICIENT WAY TO
ACCOMPLISH CYCLE. THE MY
QUESTION IS HOW DOES THIS CHANGE
THE STATUS QUO WHAT WHAT WHAT IS
SHIFTED AROUND I'VE LOST TRACK
OF EXACTLY HOW WE'RE-
INCENTIVIZING SETS PRESENTLY I
THINK IT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO
WE ALSO WE WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE
NOT JUST TO DO THAT BUT ALSO TO-
FACTOR IN INCOME. SO THE STATUS
QUO NOW IS TO CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
WHICH IS THE- ONES TARGETING
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES ARE THE
ONES. THAT ARE YOU IF YOU HAVE
LIKE A GAS GUZZLER WILL TRY TO
GET TRY TO GAS GUZZLER INTO A
CLEANER CAR. BUT THAT IS JUST
TARGETING LOWER INCOME FAMILIES
WHAT WE SAY IS BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO FACTORY AND WE THINK YOU
SHOULD HAVE A LARGER IS CENTER
FOR STATE FOR CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL- IF YOU ARE. DRIVING FURTHER
YOU'RE USING MORE GASOLINE NOW
THERE'S A CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROGRAM WHICH THE INCOME HAS
JUST RECENTLY DROPPED SO- YOU
COULD CALL IT MORE OF A MIDDLE
INCOME- PROPOSAL WHICH IS JUST
FOR NEW. CLEAN CARS SAME THING
SO IF YOU IN OVER SO I WENT
FROM. IF YOU GO FROM YOU KNOW
ELECTRACARD ANOTHER LECTURE CARP
INSTEAD OF A PART BE THE SAME
BUT IF YOU'RE GOING FROM A GAS
CAR YOU'RE DRIVING A LOT OF GAS
YOU'RE USING A LOT OF GAS. THAT
INCENTIVE WOULD BE HIGHER SO
IT'S REALLY TRYING TO. JUST
REALLY QUICK LITTLE MORE FOCUS
AROUND THAT INSTEAD OF IT IN A
PERFECT WORLD WE WOULD ACTUALLY
REALLY PROBABLY HAVE. ONE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM RATHER THAN.
YOU KNOW A NEW PROGRAM FOR ALL
THESE THINGS- BUT THAT'S NOT THE
WORLD THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW.
THANKS MY ONLY UP. IS THERE A
SORT OF DIFFERENCE IN HOW UNDER
THIS BILL HOW BUSINESS USE
VEHICLES TO BE TREATED VERSUS
PERSONAL USE VEHICLES THE REASON
I ASK IS THAT THAT CAME UP IN
THE NEWS ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED REBATE WHICH I JUST
THINK ABOUT MY DISTRICT I DRIVE
AROUND. IN IT ALL THE TIME LIKE
WE ALL DO OVER A HOMES BIG THROW
YOU DRIVE A LOT THERE EVERYBODY
DOES THERE'S NOBODY YOU SEE
DRIVING MORE THAN LIKE A
LANDSCAPER RIGHT AND IF THAT
PERSON. THE WORD INCENTIVIZE IN
A- YOU KNOW SMALLER TRUCKS TO
INTENDED BE WHAT THEY DRIVE BUT
IF THEY WERE INCENTIVIZED TO
SWITCH TO OBSERVE I COULD SEE
TREMENDOUS SAVINGS FOR THEM THE
NUMBER. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT. CARVING THEM OUT IN
SOME WAY AND IMPORTANTLY BECAUSE
THEY MAY HAVE THAT BUSINESS
THERE THAT THAT DIFFICULT MAY BE
REGISTERED AS A BUSINESS USED
VEHICLE. I'M I'M DONE GO INTO
THAT SO- I NONPROFIT HAS BEEN
DOING SOME RESEARCH AND YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE ARE SOME-
LEAD VEHICLES. THAT ARE USING
FAR DISPROPORTIONATELY YOU KNOW
LARGER AMOUNTS OF GASOLINE. AND
THOSE SHOUD BE FOCUSED ON THIS.
BILL APPLIES TO PRIVATE VEHICLE
EVEY INCENTIVE PROGRAMS BUT I
THINK YOU MAKE A GREAT POINT
THAT IT WOULD BE A REALLY GOOD
IDEA TO INCENTIVIZE THOSE USING
THE MOST GASOLINE AND OTHER. FOR
OTHER TYPES OF VEHICLES TO ALSO
SWITCH FIRST. IT THE PART THE
REASON WE HADN'T FOCUSED THERE
ARE MUCH IS. YOU ONLY HAD SEDANS
THAT WERE ELECTRIC VEHICLES VERY
FEW S. U. V. OPTIONS WERE NOW
STARTED SEE I MEAN A LANDSCAPER
COULD REALLY DO IT BECAUSE THERE
AREN'T ANY PICKUP TRUCKS. NOW
THAT THERE ARE PICKUP TRUCKS YOU
CAN POLICIES I THINK. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN START
THINKING ABOUT FOR SURE BUT THIS
DOESN'T. CHANGE ISN'T CHANGE THE
STRUCTURE OF ANY OF THE- CENTER
PROGRAMS OUTSIDE OF JUST. ASKING
THEM TO FOCUS MORE ON. WHO THE
USERS ARE AND WHO'S WHO THE
BUYERS OF THIS VEHICLE. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- THANK YOU AYE ACTUALLY I
APPRECIATE MY PREVIOUS
COLLEAGUES- QUESTION AND
COMMENTS AS WELL BECAUSE I AGREE
A LOT OF THE TIMES AND MY
DISTRICT IS SIGNIFICANTLY
SMALLER THAN HIS IT'S PROBABLY
ONLY ABOUT TEN SQUARE MILES BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHO DRIVES AT
THE MOST IT'S USUALLY
LANDSCAPING CONSTRUCTION FOLKS
SO- SO LONG AS THERE. GIVEN THE
AND SEND IT EXTENDED THE
INCENTIVE IS WELL I THINK
THAT'LL GO A LONG WAY FOR A LOT
OF THESE FOLKS- AND AGAIN ONCE
AGAIN ONCE THE WE HAVE CORPS
MIGHT BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
BECAUSE I SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE FOR A
SECOND AND TAKE ROLL CALL
BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE A QUORUM SO
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. IN HERE FRIEDMAN HERE
FONG ON HERE BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HERE DAILY. DAVIES.
DAVIES HERE GIPSON ALL RIGHT.
OVER HERE WE LEE HERE MEDINA.
THIS AREA. JERRY IN HERE WHEN.
DONALD WARD. HERE WICKS. SEVEN
MISSING. THERE'S EIGHT OF US
HERE DID I MISS I DON'T KNOW
FRIEDMAN HERE FONG HERE
CUNNINGHAM HERE. DAVIES HERE ALL
RIGHTS HERE LEASE HERE WARD WARD
. WARD YEAH I HAVE OWNERS THERE
WERE OKAY EIGHT OKAY WE ARE OUR
- THANK YOU. SO WHETHER OTHER
COMMENTS- ABOUT THE BILL. I'LL
MAKE MY COMMENT I HOPE MISTER
WARD WE SET A FINGER OKAY VERY
SECOND AUCTIONEERING. M. HAND
GESTURES- OKAY WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF MOTIONS AND A SECOND I THINK
THIS IS A POTENTIALLY VERY
INTERESTING CONCEPT I THINK WE
HAVE TO STILL DO SOME MORE WORK
ON IT- HAPPY TO SEE IT MOVE
TODAY YOU KNOW WE ARE TRYING TO
MOVE TO A INSTEAD OF THIS WORLD
AND IT ALSO WOULD BE INTERESTING
TO SEE AT SOME POINT THROUGH
DATA HOW MUCH THE INCENTIVES
MOVE THE NEEDLE IN THE PASSENGER
SPACE- I'VE SPOKEN TO SOME
GROUPS. IN SOME AREAS WHO SAY
THAT IT'S THE LACK OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THEIR AREA
THAT'S MUCH MORE BARRIER TO
PEOPLE THAT THEY SITE- YOU KNOW
OTHER TYPES OF ISSUES SO- YOU
KNOW I THINK AS WE START SEEING
MORE AND AS WE MOVE MORE TOWARDS
THAT THE FUTURE IT'LL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT DOES
CHANGE PEOPLE'S BUYING HABITS IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE IN
A DIFFERENT POPULATIONS OVER
TIME- BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR FOCUSING AND DRILLING DOWN
ON THIS AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BEFORE WE TAKE A VOTE THE RIVER
REALLY PRETTY I THINK- YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS ARE RIGHT SPOT ON I
THINK- NOW THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
THESE ARE PROGRAMS FOR QUITE A
NUMBER OF YEARS I THINK IT'S
REALLY TIME TO TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK YOU KNOW SEE WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT WORKING I THINK WE
ALL HAVE A LOT OF ASSUMPTIONS AS
TO WHAT WOULD WORK NOT NOW THAT
WE HAVE SOME DATA. AND I THINK
THIS DID THIS BILLS IDEA IS
REALLY- USING EVEN MORE
INFORMATION TO REALLY SEE IF WE
CAN CREATE AN INCENTIVE TO MOVE
THAT PERSON WHO REALLY
TRADITIONALLY HAS BEEN MOVED UP
WITHTHAT THANK YOU FOR THE
SUPPORT AND VITIATED BY FAST.
FIVE THANK YOU SOMUCH WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB TWO EIGHT
SIXTEEN TO PASS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN
HI FONG. FONG NO BERMAN.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I DALY.
DAVIES AV'S NO GIPSON. KALRA ALL
RIGHT I LI LI I MEDINA. THIS
AREA THIS AREA AND I WENT.
O'DONNELL WARD WARD I WICKS. SIX
ONE SIX ONE LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR UP TO MEMBERS THANK YOU. SIX
TWO LIBERAL A PROFESSOR MEMBERS
I APOLOGIZE IF YOU SEE HOW MUCH
IT'S QUITE ALRIGHT- WE WILL TAKE
MR FONG NEXT.
I THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS I AM
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BUILD SIXTEEN SEMI NINE IS
MEASURE WILL BRING RESILIENCE
AND EFFICIENCY THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPLY CHAIN THIS BILL ESTABLISH
A SINGLE HIGH LEVEL POSITION
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THE SERVE AS A
SENIOR ADVISER ON THE SUPPLY
CHAIN TO THE DIRECTOR OF GOBIZ.
THIS SENIOR ADVISER WILL BE THE
PRINCIPAL ADVOCATE FOR THE
STATE'S SUPPLY CHAIN AND WILL
WORK BETWEEN INDUSTRIES AND
STATE GOVERNMENT ON ISSUES
AFFECTING GOODS MOVEMENT IN AND
OUT OF TIMES OF CRISIS. THERE
ARE ELEVEN MAJOR DEEP WATER
PORTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA OVER
FOUR HUNDRED BILLION OF CARGO
THEY'LL MOVE TO THE PORTS OF LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH EVERY
YEAR HELPING GOOD TO MOVE OUT OF
THE PORTS IT'S CRITICAL TO OUR
LONG TERM HEALTH OF OUR ECONOMY.
BUT THIS CRISIS STRETCHES BEYOND
OUR PORTS INCLUDING CHALLENGES
AFFECTING RAIL TRUCKING AND
DISTRIBUTION FACILITIES CENTRAL
VALLEY FARMERS ARE SUFFERING AS
WELL OUR STATES WERE KNOWN
RENOWNED OF FRESH FRUITS ARE NOW
BEING EXPORTED. ARE NOT BEING
EXPORTED AS THEY WOULD IN A
NORMAL YEAR IN FACT FARMERS ARE
SEEING A 20% REDUCTION IN THEIR
EXPORT OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE OF
THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS WITH SO
MANY MOVING PARTS IN ENTITIES
INVOLVED BETTER COLLABORATION
AND COORDINATION WILL ENSURE THE
SUPPLY CHAIN IS FUNCTIONING. AB
SIXTEEN THREE NINE CREATE A HIGH
LEVEL ADVISER TO MEET THESE
UNIQUE NEEDS THE ADVISER WILL
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA'S GOOD
MOVEMENT SECTOR EXPEDITE
IMPROVEMENTS AND SWIFTLY MOVED
HURDLES IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN TO
ENSURE EFFICIENCY AN ADDRESS
CHOKEPOINTS SUCH A POSITION IT
WILL ALSO BE TASKED TO MAKE SURE
THAT LONG TERM SOLUTIONS ARE
IMPLEMENTED AS WELL. THEY WERE
ADVOCATE AT THE HERE SHE WILL
ADVOCATES- IMPROVE SUPPLY CHAIN
FUNCTIONS AND PROVIDE A VENUE
FOR SUPPLY CHAIN STAKEHOLDERS TO
REACH THEIR GOVERNMENT AND
BUDGET SUB THREE A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO IT BECAME CLEAR THAT THERE
IS NO CLEAR POINT PERSON
KALISKA. SAID THAT THEY ARE THE
LEAD AGENCY ON SUPPLY CHAIN BUT
WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE DETAILS OF
THEIR BUDGET PROPOSAL THEY
DEFERRED TO GULBIS. AB SIXTY
SEVEN NINE WILL BRING LEADERSHIP
AND COORDINATION TO CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPLY CHAIN OPERATIONS I'M
JOINED TODAY BY MIKE JAKE UP
WITH PACIFIC WHICH IT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION. AND MARTHA MILLER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PORT AUTHORITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TWO MINUTES
FOR EACH WITNESS. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S MARTHA MILLER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PART
OF THIRTIES WHICH CONSISTS OF
ELEVEN COMMERCIAL SEAPORTS IN
CALIFORNIA HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
NINE. AT THE PORTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE IN CALIFORNIA
RESPONSIBLE FOR HANDLING 30% OF
ALL CONTAINERIZED IMPORTS AND
20% OF ALL THE EXPERTS IN THE U.
S. ADDITIONALLY OVER THREE POINT
ONE MILLION JOBS ARE SUPPORTED
BY THE TRADE THAT MR CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE THE CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
OF FREE TO CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE AND ECONOMY THE RECENT
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS IS SHOWING
THAT CALIFORNIANS FREIGHT SECTOR
S IN NEED OF BETTER PLANNING
AND COORDINATION ACROSS
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. IN RESPONSE
TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS THE
BY ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZING
THE NEED FOR CENTRALIZED
LEADERSHIP APPOINTED A PORT
ENVOY TO ME ACROSS SECTORS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS NATIONAL SUPPLY
CHAIN TO MITIGATE THE CONGESTION
A REAL TIME WE SAW THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS APPROACH.
AND WHILE GO BIZ AND CAL STEP
TAKEN LEADERSHIP ROLES IN
FACILITATING COORDINATION THERE
IS CURRENTLY NO STATE ENTITY
OFFICE OR POSITION WITH THE
AUTHORITY AND CAPACITY ACCORDING
TO CROSS THE ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAIN. AND SUPPORTING AGENCIES
ADDITIONALLY IN A JANUARY FOURTH
LETTER THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
REQUESTED THE EACH STATE
DESIGNATED COORDINATOR TO MANAGE
THE SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT DOLLARS WILL BE
ALLOCATED TO THE STATES WE
BELIEVE THIS POSITIONAL SERVICE
OUT AS WELL. STATES LIKE NEW
MEXICO AND ARKANSAS I'VE ALREADY
TAKEN THIS IMPORTANT STEP. UP
ALONG WITH OTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE GOODS
MOVEMENT SECTOR INCLUDING DOVE
IS COST ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE PARTICIPATED IN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPLY CHAIN SUCCESS
SUMMIT THIS PAST FALL THE KEY
FINDING FROM THE SUMMIT WHICH
AIMS TO ADDRESS THE COMPLEX
CHALLENGES FACING OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN. WAS THAT OUR STATE MUST
DEVELOP A CENTRIC MUST DEVELOP A
CENTRALIZED AN ELEVATED POSITION
RESPONSIBLE FOR IDENTIFYING AND
SETTING CLEAR GOALS GOALS THAT
PROMOTE ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS. IN THE CALIFORNIA GETS
MOVEMENT FACTOR. AB SIXTEEN
SEVEN NINE WILL DO. ADDRESS THIS
RECOMMENDATION BY ESTABLISHING A
SUPPLY CHAIN COORDINATOR
POSITION WITHIN GOBIZ. TO MANAGE
GOODS MOVEMENT ACROSS AGENCIES
AND STIR COMPETITIVENESS AND
SUSTAINABILITY ACROSS THE
FREIGHT SECTOR. AS WE LOOK TO
THE FUTURE AND CONTINUE TO WORK
ON SOLUTIONS THAT WILL HELP GET
KIDS MOVING FASTER WE BELIEVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SMARTER
COORDINATION WITHIN STATE
LEADERSHIP IS CRITICAL. THANK
YOU WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
WORK WITH YOU AND HAPPY ANSWER
QUESTIONS. PERFECT NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY CHECK ABOUT THAT
SUBMERGES HAVING ASSOCIATION
AND- WE- LIKE OUR- COLLEAGUES
ARE KAPPA- PARTICIPATED IN THE
SUMMIT THAT WAS HOSTED- IN THE
FALL- AGAIN. THE NUMBER ONE
RECOMMENDATION OUT OF THAT-
GATHERING OF FOLKS WERE LOOKING
AT ALL OF OUR SUPPLY CHAIN
CHALLENGES. WITH RESPECT TO
STATE GOVERNMENT WAS TO ASK.
WHO'S IN CHARGE. IS THE POINT
PERSON WHO WE GOING TO LOOK TO
MAKE THESE- CHALLENGES. WORK
WHEN WE ACTUALLY HAVE SOLUTIONS.
NOT THAT WE HAVE ALL THE
SOLUTIONS BUT IF WE DID. WOULD
BE THE PERSON WHO IS GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTING THEM HELPING US
WORK THROUGH ALL OF THESE.
ISSUES OF THE STATE. AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS RIGHTFULLY
POINTS OUT. BERRIER MORE
RESOURCES BEING BROUGHT TO BEAR
WITH RESPECT SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS
AND WE WELCOME THAT. THERE ARE
MORE RESOURCES A CAL STAR BEING
BROUGHT TO BEAR WITH RESPECT TO
COORDINATION ACROSS PROGRAMS AT
THAT AGENCY LEVEL WE WELCOME
THAT. THERE'S MORE SENSITIVITY
TO THIS ISSUE- WITH OUR FRIENDS
AT THEIR RESOURCES BOARD. WE
WELCOME THAT. BUT THAT DOES NOT
ALSO INCLUDE THE SAME TYPE OF
LEVEL COORDINATION THERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME LEVEL OF
THAT FOR YOU SEE THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN WITHIN GO BIZ- YOU'RE ALL
VERY FAMILIAR WITH GO BUSINESS
MISSION IT'S SPECIFICALLY TO
ADVOCATE. FOR AND MARKET FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
SOMETHING OUR COMPETITORS DO.
THE STATE OF TAX THE STATE OF
FLORIDA. OTHER NATIONS THEY ARE
ASKING FOR COMPETING FOR
DISCRETIONARY CARGO EVEN WITHOUT
COATED. IN THIS ERA IN THE FACE
OF WHAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH
RIGHT NOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS POSITION IS HERE. IT'S
ROBUST AS WE COME OUT WE'RE
USING IT TO LEVERAGES MANY
RESOURCES WE CAN. SO THANK YOU
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S
ANOTHER. BILL MOVING FORWARD AT
THE SAME TIME WE'RE SUPPORTING
THAT ONE AS WELL IT'S BY THE
CHAIR OF THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. AND
WE'RE THANKFUL FOR BUSINESS MR
FONG IN THIS GONZALEZ FOR MOVING
FOR WITH THESE CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT.
OF AB. IXTEEN SEVENTY NINE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KRISHNADAS
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. REX W. HYMAN CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DO HAVE ONE
WITNESS LIST OF THE IN
OPPOSITION TO RESEAL BOISE FROM
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT IF OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR THE OPPOSITION WITNESS. ONE MOMENT. AND THE DEADLINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR FRIEDMAN AND MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS TREAT ABILITY WITH THE
ABOUT NOW NONPROFIT PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENT BE HOLD A
COMPLICATED STATUS BUT THE
INTERNATIONAL MARITIME
ORGANIZATION WHICH SETS GLOBAL
SHIPPING LAW. WE ARE HAVE A
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
TO AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE OUR
BIGGEST CONCERN IS THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
THE PEOPLE MOST IMPACTED BY THE
PORT CONGESTION CRISIS THOSE
LIVING IN QUITE COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
ENVIRONMENTAL OR COMMUNITY
CONSIDERATION IN THE BILL WE
VIEW ANOTHER BILL GOING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE S. B. ELEVEN OH
FOUR BY SENATOR GONZALEZ AS MUCH
MORE BALANCED AND CHAIR. OF THE
PORT CONGESTION CRISIS IS NOT
JUST AN ECONOMIC CRISIS AGAIN
THANK YOU PUBLIC HEALTH ONE AND
EXPOSING OUT- CLIMATE ONE. CARD
HAS CONDUCTED EMISSION ANALYSIS
OF THE PORT CONGESTION AND THEY
FOUND THAT LAST YEAR IT CARGO
CONGESTION ACCENTED REPORT HAS
CAUSED AN INCREASE OF NOT
CONDITION THAT THE CLIENT TO
FIVE POINT EIGHT MILLION
PASSENGER CARS IN SOUTH COAST
PER DAY AND INCREASE THE PROJECT
A MATTER. THAT THEY COVERED A
HUNDRED THOUSAND A GREAT. TRACKS
KERR DAY. HE POLLUTION. KILLING
COURT RESIDENT OF CHAIR I
THOUGHT RECKONED. WE HAVE OR
SPEAK TO THE BILL. WE IS TO
POINT SOMEONE SPECIFIC. THEY
HANDLE THE CARGO. GESTURE AIR
POLLUTION IS SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPORTANT MATTER BUT I DON'T
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL. I WAS
WITNESS SALUTE TO FIND A NEXUS
BETWEEN THE IF THERE IS A NEXUS
BETWEEN THE AIR POLLUTION ISSUE
AND THE BILL MAYBE TO SPEAK TO
THAT. YEAH SO I RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS TO ADD AN APARTMENT
ON COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION ON
THE BY THREE GROUPS AND THAT THE
ADVISOR GROUP WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS. SO
THAT ANY FOR A POLICY
RECOMMENDATION IS CONSISTENT
WITH MEETING THE STATE'S
EMISSION REDUCTION REQUIREMENTS
AS WELL- BUT THEY CAN'T EASE UP
ON ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
BECAUSE- WE HAVE TO MEET THE
CLEAN AIR ATTAINMENT. AND THE
FACT BECAUSE ABOUT RECORDS
MISSING FEDERAL FUNDING AS THE
NEXT P. CLEAN AIR AT KING RANCH. ARE YOU FINISHED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. YEAH OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. OKAY
SEEING NINE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
NINE THANK YOU. Q. AND LAID IN
GENERAL IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTY SEVEN MPS
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. OVERLIE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DANIEL BROWN IN THE HAPLESS CARE
CLUB CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
APPLICATION AND MIND WHAT THE
TESTIMONY FROM PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU. EXHORT A
LINE NUMBER TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI THIS IS RYAN ELAINE WITTY
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN LAYS JUMP YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB SIXTEEN SEVEN NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND YOUR PERSONAL
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL
GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE
IF ANYBODY HAS ANYTHING THEY'D
LIKE TO SAY MISTER O'DONNELL.
YES SIR THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
FONG FOR THE BILL IT'S A GREAT
IDEA IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S- VERY
MUCH NEEDED- AS THE PORT CRISIS
CAME UPON US- I DIDN'T KNOW WHO
TO CALL THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
RIGHT THERE WERE NOT ENOUGH
pCOULDN'T TELL WHO TO CALL QUITE
FRANKLY. SO WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO SET UP HERE IS REALLY A POINT
PERSON INDIVIDUAL. TO DEAL WITH
THIS CRISIS AND THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY WHAT WE NEED AND THEN
THE HOUSE PERSON. TO DEAL WITH
THIS CRISIS AND LISTEN CAN MORE
CONGESTION MEANS MORE POLLUTION.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
GET RID OF YOUR SO I APPRECIATE
THAT AS THE ONE. WHO REPRESENTS-
THE LARGEST PORT COMPLEX IN THE
UNITED STATES I KNOW THE ISSUES
VERY WELL BUT NOT EVERYBODY ELSE
TO US AND WE NEED AN IN HOUSE
EXPERT. IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
WHOSE AGO TOO SO WE CAN GET
THESE ISSUES ADDRESSED AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEKING TO
CREATE TODAY. AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT AS JUST MY
COMMUNITY WHO WANTS TO GET RID
OF CONGESTION AND WANTS TO GET
RID OF THE POLLUTION AND THIS
WILL HELP TO THAT SO I THANK
YOU. I JUST WANT TO COMMEND THE
CHAIR OF THE SELECT BOARD'S
COMMITTEE. YOUR THAT YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AS WELL YOUR
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA. THINK ABOUT CHEN
AND- BUT THINK IS A MEMBER FONG-
FOR BRING FOR THIS BUT I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THAT- POINT PERSON ONE QUESTION
I HAVE IS THAT IT- INDICATES IN
THE- IN REGARDS TO ADVISORY
GROUPS- THIS IS CONSISTING
HOLDERS IN THE STATE'S SUPPLY
CHAIN AND SPECIFIES A MEMBERSHIP
AND BY SCREAMING COOPER IS NOT
LIMITED TO REPRESENTATIVES FROM
EACH SECTOR THE MAKES OF THE
STATE'S SUPPLY CHAIN IS TO FIND-
SO THAT MEANS. IT MOTORS IBM
SECTION DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES OR
DIFFERENT- KIND OF PIECES OF THE
PUZZLE ALONG THE SUPPLY CHAIN
OUR GOAL IS TO OF COURSE HAVE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN THE GOODS MOVEMENT SECTOR NOW
WE ARE OPEN TO INCLUDING OTHER
GROUPS AS AS- AS A CHAIR THE
SUPPORT COMMITTEE SAID WE ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE CONGESTION
AT THE PORTS. NO ONE WANTS- YOU
KNOW IDOLING SHIPS OFF THE COAST
OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE THAT'S
BURNING BUNKER FUEL ON WANTS
TRUCKERS A WAITING FOR FOUR
HOURS- CONGESTED AT THE PORTS NO
ONE WANTS AND THE CONTAINERS-IN
THE COMMUNITIES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS NEIGHBORING- THE
PORTS SO WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE SUPPLY CHAIN IS A
RESILIENT YET EFFICIENT- TO SO
THAT WE CAN MOVE THE GOODS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CALIFORNIA.
HAS ANY INTENTION OF HAVING
SPECIFICITY IN TERMS OF HAVING A
LABOR REPRESENTATIVE IN THE
ADVISORY. OR HAPPY TED SAID TO
HELP WORK OUT THE SPECIFICS- AS
WELL AS BEFORE BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY RIGHT NOW THERE IS JUST
NO ONE. IN CHARGE. AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO. WE SHOULD
THE NEED TO HAVE A ONE POINT
PERCENT ALL OF THAT DID
CERTAINLY SEEM TO BE AN ISSUE
AND- WE ARE HAVING SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES BUT IN TERMS OF. IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ADVISING TO
HAVE A CROSS SECTION. OF
STAKEHOLDERS IN INTERESTS THAT-
TO ADVISE THEM SO THAT THEY COME
THE- NUMBER OF WHICH I'M WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO THE
STAKEHOLDER PART- INTO THAT TO
THE COMMITTEE PART. WHICH WHAT
SOMEONE IN CHARGE. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE THE STATUS. I THANK
YOU SIMILAR FONG THIS IS A GREAT
BILL I REALLY LOOK AT IS A WIN
WIN. AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING AT-
MAKING SURE THAT WE'VE GOT GOOD
AIR QUALITY BUT ALSO MAKING
MOVEMENT ON GOOD SO. I THANK YOU
AND I'D LIKE TO CO AUTHOR. THANK
YOU. THANK ANYBODY ELSE. THANK
YOU I DO ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS AND THINK THAT THE
INCREASE COORDINATION IS
ESSENTIAL I'M REALLY HAPPY THAT
YOU BROUGHT THIS BEFORE AND I'LL
BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE A
UNITED FRONT DO YOU ADDRESS THIS
BUDGET CRISIS INTEREST IN OUR
STATE AND I WAS SO THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY MAYBE ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FONG. AYE FONG AYE
BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I
DALY. DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON
GIPSON I KALRA KALRA NOT VOTING
LEE. LEE NOT VOTING MEDINA. THE
SYRIAN. WHEN O'DONNELL DONALD I
WORK WARD I WICKS. SIX ZERO SIX
ZERO WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS SICK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER GIBSON YOU'RE
UP NEXT.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
WHICH SEEKS TO DEVELOP THE
CREATION. OF A VIDEO
DEMONSTRATING PROPER CONDUCT
BETWEEN AN INDIVIDUAL DRIVER AND
OFFICER DURING A TRAFFIC STOP.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS TRAINING TO POST A
VIDEO ON THEIR INTERNET WEBSITE.
THIS BILL ALSO WILL ALLOW THE
DMV TO POST OF THIS VIDEO ON
THEIR WEBSITE AND TO INFORM
APPLICANTS OF THE ORIGINAL THEIR
RENEWAL OR DUPLICATION. OF
DRIVER LICENSE ON THEIR OWN
EXISTING VIDEOS. LASTLY THIS
BILL REQUIRES A DRIVER EDUCATION
IN SCHOOLS TO CONDUCT- AND MAKE
SURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE VIEW
SUCH VIDEO. LET ME PAUSE THERE
AND SIMPLY SAY THAT I WAS ABLE
TO WATCH A MOVIE SOME YEARS AGO
I TOOK THREE HUNDRED- YOUNG
pCITY OF CARSON WELL WE SAW A
MOVIE CALLED THE HATE U. GIVE
THE HATE- THE HATE U. GIVE. AND
IS BY- DIRECTED BY GEORGE
TILLMAN JUNIOR AND ALSO STARRING
RUSSELL HORNSBY IN THAT MOVIE-
IT SHOWED A YOUNG DRIVER MAKING
AN ILLEGAL U. TURN WITH HIS
GIRLFRIEND AND AS SOON AS A
POLICE OFFICER STOPPED THEM- SHE
IMMEDIATELY DEAL WITH HER FATHER
TOLD HER TO DO. A POLICE OFFICER
STOP YOU PUT YOUR HEART YOUR
HANDS ON THE STEERING WHEEL
BETWEEN NINE O'CLOCK AND THREE
O'CLOCK AND COMPLY WITH THIS
YOUNG MAN DIDN'T COMPLY AS A
MATTER OF FACT THE POLICE
OFFICER TOLD HIM STAY IN HIS
CAR. OUR MANY WITHOUT HIS CAR
AND RAN PLEASE OFFICER TOLD TO
STAY THERE I'M HERE REACHED IN
HIS CAR GOT A BRUSH AND THE
OFFICER ON UNFORTUNATELY- TOOK
ACTION SHOT THE YOUNG MAN. AND
SO FROM THERE. MANY OF YOU KNOW
I WAS A LAW ENFORCEMENT- AND
IT'S A TOUGH TOUGH JOB AND AS
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE AND
FATHER- WE CANNOT ASSUME THAT A
PARENTS- TELLS THEIR TEACHER
CHILD ONE NOW IT IS AND HOW TO
DRIVE- BUT ALSO THE DO'S AND THE
DON'TS EXPRESSION WHEN YOU BEEN
PULLED OVER. BY POLICE OFFICERS
THIS IS FOR PROTECTION FOR
POLICE OFFICERS AS WELL AS THE
DRIVER ITSELF. THIS TALK IS NOT
ABOUT HOW TO AVOID BEING
ARRESTED BUT THIS TALK IS ABOUT
GETTING HOME SAFE NOT ONLY FOR
THE OFFICER BUT ALSO FOR THE
DRIVER. AS WELL THIS TALK I'VE
HAD WITH MY OLD SON AND SONS I'M
TO MAKING SURE JORDAN WHEN YOU
PLEASE WHEN A POLICE OFFICER
STOP YOU. PUT YOUR HANDS ON THE
STEERING WHEEL WAS PLAIN VIEW.
JORDAN MAKE SURE THAT YOU MAKE
NO SUDDEN MOVEMENTS UNNECESSARY
MOVEMENTS JORDAN MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN YOU LEAVE HOME YOUR DRIVER
LICENSE IS IN YOUR POCKET MAKING
SURE THAT YOUR VOTE YOUR TO
REGISTRATION IS IN THE GLOVE BOX
AND PROOF OF INSURANCE. MAKING
SURE WHATEVER HAPPENS OUT THERE
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO COME HOME SAFE
SAFELY AND I AM STILL THAT BUT
WE CAN'T TAKE A TAKE US OR SOON
THAT EVERY PARENT GIVE THEIR
CHILD THOSE KINDS OF
INSTRUCTIONS. THIS BILL TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN SEEKS TO
DEVELOP AND CREATE A VIDEO
DEMONSTRATING THE PROPER CONDUCT
BETWEEN BOTH. PARTIES THE
INDIVIDUAL DRIVER AND ALSO THE
POLICE OFFICER MAKING THE STOP
AS WELL FOR THE DRIVER ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
WOULD REQUIRE- VIEWING THE VIDEO
ON PROPER CONDUCT- DURING A
TRAFFIC STOP AS AS PART OF THE
COURSE OF DRIVERS TRAINING. THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRES A DMV
TO POST THIS PUBLICLY. I'M SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN SEE IT AND
PEOPLE CAN VIEW IT ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO RENEW ANALYZE AND
THOSE WHO ARE FIRST ON TIME
DRIVERS THIS ALSO AT. PEACE FOR
DRY IN EDUCATE. THAT WILL
SUPPORT OF VISUAL LEARNERS AS
WELL AS NON. ENGLISH SPEAKING
RESIDENTS CITIZENS THIS BILL
PROVIDES A PREVENTATIVE MEASURE
AND A SAFETY GUARD- WHEN DRIVING
BEING STOPPED BY POLICE OFFICERS
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE FOR TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IF WE HAVE A MOTION DO YOU
HAVE A WITNESS THANK YOU. YOU
HAVE A WITNESS WITH YOU TODAY I
DO NOT OKAY- AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES ALL US
WITH IT'S ANYBODY IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHICH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TO COME FORWARD. IF
THERE'S ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD. OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU AND LAYS
NEXT GERMAN IF YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. LET'S GET THIS ONE
DONE ZERO FEAR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB. TWO FIVE THREE
SEVEN. THE CHAIR PERSON AT THIS
TIME I HAVE NO LEARNING QUEUE
OKAY WE'LL GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYBODY HAS
ANYTHING. THEY WOULD LIKE TO ASK
OR SAY. SEEING NINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AGAIN FOR THE
OFFICER EVERY SITUATION IS
DIFFERENT- BUT THIS VIDEO
REQUIRES A REQUIREMENT IN AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN AS A
REMINDER. OF WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
I'M FROM BOTH LAND TO SERVING
AND PROTECTING AND ALSO IT
PROVIDES EDUCATION- SPECIALLY
FOR THOSE WHO ARE FIRST TIME-
LICENSEES THOSE WHO ARE FIRST
TIME DRIVING. TO MAKING SURE
THAT YOU KNOW NOW THE RULES OF
THE ROAD BUT ALSO IT WHAT
HAPPENS- AND WHAT YOU SHOULD DO
WHEN GETTING STOPPED BY POLICE
OFFICER MOVING FOR SO I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION THAT WE
HAVE A SECOND. OKAY WE ROLL CALL
PLEASE. AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN DO PASSED TO PUBLIC SAFETY
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FONG
THANK YOU. FONG I BERMAN BERMAN
I CUNNINGHAM. DALY. DAVIES
DAVIES I'D GIPSON I GIPSON AYE
KALRA KALRA I LI LI I MEDINA.
THE SYRIAN. WHEN DONALD. SO
DONALD I WARD. WARD I WICKS.
NINE ZERO ENTER THE BILL ITSELF
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER LEE.
YOU'RE WELCOME 2% TWENTY TWO OH
SIX. NO I'M SORRY. TWENTY NINE
FORTY NINE. AND YOU HAVE A
SUPPORT SUPPORT ANIMOTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SHARE MEMBERS
I'LL BE BRIEF THIS BILL AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY NINE WOULD
EXEMPT VEHICLES REGISTERED TO A
U. S. MILITARY VETERAN
DISPLAYING LICENSE PLATE
INDICATES THAT THEY ARE A
DISABLED VETERAN OR PEARL HARBOR
SURVIVOR OR FOR PRISONER OF WAR
A CONGRESSIONAL MEDAL OF HONOR
RECIPIENT OPERABLE HEART
RECIPIENT OR MEMBER OF THE
LEGION OF VALOR. OR ARMY
DISTINGUISHED SERVICE CROSS AND
THE NAVY AND AIR FORCE CROSSES
HE'S RIGHT VETERANS WOULD BE
EXEMPT FROM PAYING TOLLS
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT NEARLY THREE
IN TEN DISABLED VETERANS SAY
THEIR IMPAIRMENTS PREVENT THEM
FROM GETTING OR KEEPING A JOB AT
SOME POINT THEIR WORKING LIVES
THE NUMBER JUMPS TWO OUT OF
THREE WHEN THE PERSON IS A 100%
FABLED. EDITION MANY DISABLED
VETERANS HAVE TO USE TOLL ROADS
THAT ACCESS ONGOING MEDICAL
TREATMENT AND ARE VETERANS
SHOULD NOT BE FURTHER BURDEN I
TOLD COSTA C. HEALTHCARE I ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME IN SUPPORT AND
SHOWING GRATITUDE FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE SACRIFICED SO MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING MY BILL TO PROVIDE
OUR VETERANS FINANCIAL RELIEF.
TODAY ON THE PHONE I'LL BE
JOINED BY A FREMONT RESIDENT
CITY THAT GETS REPRESENT A
CURTIS BROWN WHO IS A US MARINE
CORPS VETERAN THANK YOU OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR MISTER BRIAN. HELLO MY
UP. YES YOU ARE. YES MISS READY
LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME TEST FOR
INDIANAPOLIS. I WOULD LIKE TO
THE PASSAGE OF NUMBERS CONSERVE
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD HELP
ALL OF US DISABLED VETERANS I
MYSELF. AM A L. LIKE MR
RESETTING CAN RECORD AFTER AND I
AM NOW A QUADRIPLEGIC. ID ONE
ACCIDENT- IN THIS BILL WITHOUT
IS THAT MY FAMILY AND A LOT OF
MONEY I COME MONEY WILL WORK
BECAUSE OF MY INJURIES SO- WERE
OF COURSE A VERY LIMITED BUDGET
AND HAVING ACROSS TOLL BRIDGES
TO GO. TO IMPLEMENT MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS OVER THE CITY OF
PALO ALTO- HELP ME QUITE OFTEN.
IT ENDS UP BEING A PRETTY
COSTLY- SIX WE JUST DON'T GET IN
THE NECESSARY CARE FOR MY
INJURIES. SO I'M NOT ALONE IN
THIS THERE'S LOTS OF VETERANS IN
THE IN THE UNITED STATES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT THAT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE SAME THINGS I DO.
SOME OF THEM KAMLAGER BUT EVEN
GOING TO YOU KNOW TO RETREAT
OVERAGES TO GET TO AND FROM
THEIR JOB EVERY DAY. IT ADDS UP.
pCAN BE HUNDRED DOLLARS IMPORT
FEES. AND IT INCREASE UNDUE
HARDSHIP ON ALL OF US. SO I
WOULD ASK YOU WILL CONSIDER
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHAT WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR OR IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THESE
COME UP TO THE MIKE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RUSKO K.
YOUNG YOUNG LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
TO SAVE OUR SENIORS NETWORK
WORKING WITH FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBERMARTY COLE
YAMADA. IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN FAVOR OR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY NINE. THANK YOU ONE CAN
LAY GENERAL JONES FORD OR
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE YOU HAVE THAT
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. OVERLIE NUMBER SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BETTINGER THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR I REPRESENT THE
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR AGENCIES
THOSE ARE THE ORANGE COUNTY TOLL
ROADS ARE BOARDS HAVE NOT TAKEN
A POSITION BUT WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN
AT YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB
TWO NINE FOUR NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. ENSURE
PERSON AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
WANTING TO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. LADIES THANK YOU UN
THIS IS A GREAT BILL OF I DON'T
THINK WE CAN NEVER DO ENOUGH FOR
THAT SO ON THANKS FR BRINGING
THIS UP AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE A
CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANT TO COMMEND. THE
AUTHOR OF A GREAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- I THINK IT'S- IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY ESPECIALLY
HELP THOSE WHO ARE. COMING BACK
HOME TO SERVE HIS COUNTRY AND-
SPECIALLY THOSE- THAT YOU MADE
MENTION THAT THIS BILL WILL
COVER I'M EXCITED I WOULD LOVE
TO BE CONSIDERED AS A-
PRINCIPLE. THANK YOU I'M SORRY I
SHOULD IS A JOINT. THANK YOU
GIPSON. THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
HEY MISTER O'DONNELL YEAH I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR OF RIAS
FOR THE GREAT AMERICAN BILL.
SINCE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
SIGNINGS A GREAT MOMENT IT'S A
GREAT MOMENT IN THE STATE
CAPITAL FOR MISS LANE I'M
CALLING AND WITH THAT I KNOW
ABOUT HONESTLY TRUTHFULLY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I DON'T SEE
ANYONE ELSE- AB BUT THIS IS A OF
A VERY GOOD- BILL VERY GOOD
CONCEPT TO THE CERTAINLY THERE
ARE SOME LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
BILL AND HOW IT'S GOING TO WORK
FOR TOLLING AGENCIES WHICH I
TRUST YOU WILL. CONTINUE TO WORK
ON A ONE OF THE PROUDEST OF
PARTS OF MY FAMILY IS MY GREAT
UNCLE WHO IS STILL LIVING IN AS
A WORLD WAR TWO VETERAN. AND IS
DISABLED I CERTAINLY CAN'T DRIVE
BECAUSE HE'S BLIND BUT RESHAPED
THE- ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THIS SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
HER COMEDIC A ROLL CALL MACASSA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CAN HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY NINE DO PASSED A MILITARY
AND VETERANS AFFAIRS. FRIEDMAN I
FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG I BERMAN.
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALY.
DAVIES DAVIES I'D GIPSON GIPSON
AYE KALRA NOT GOING TO MISS THE
CHANCE TO MEMBERS ARE. KALRA LEE
- LEE AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
NAZARIAN. WHEN O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I WORKED. WARD I WEEKS. ZERO AND THERE THAT BILLS THAT
I'M GOING TO PASS THE GAVEL TO
MY VERY CAPABLE VICE CHAIR
MISTER FONG TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FOUR. A PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I THANK YOU I WILL ALSO BE BRIEF
WITH THIS BILL- THIS IS A BILL
TO HELP REMOVE UP WHAT A
WILDLIFE FROM OUR HIGHWAYS- AND
TO PRODUCE TO HELP CALTRANS
DEVELOP MORE WILDLIFE COOPER
CROSSINGS AND UNDER CROSSINGS TO
BOTH PROTECT BIODIVERSITY ALLOW
MIGRATORY ANIMALS TO MIGRATE.
BUT TO ALSO PROTECT HUMAN BEINGS
AND LIFE AND SAFETY BY GETTING
LARGE MIGRATORY ANIMALS LIKE
DEER OUT OF OUR HIGHWAYS WHERE
THERE ARE EVERY YEAR LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA CAUSED BY COLLISIONS
WITH THESE ANIMALS NOW THE ONLY
QUESTION I'VE HAD ON THIS BILL
HAS BEEN ABOUT THE FUNDING AND I
DO WANT TO POINT OUT. THAT WHILE
THE COST OF THESE OVER CROSSINGS
CAMBY HI BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR WILDLIFE PROJECTS
LIKE THIS AS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ALLOCATED SIXTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD
WILDLIFE CROSSINGS ACROSS THE
STATE AND PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT JOBS
ACT INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS NATIONWIDE
OVER FIVE YEARS FOR A PILOT
PROGRAM. AND ADDS WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING UNDER THE
NASH UNDER THE FREIGHT AND
HIGHWAY PROGRAM HAT FOR US NOT
TO HAVE A PROGRAM LIKE THIS TO
FORMALIZE WAYS FOR CALTRANS TO
EVALUATE THE BEST PLACE FOR
THESE CROSSINGS COULD LEAVE
CALIFORNIA TO LEAVE FEDERAL
MONEY ON THE TABLE WHICH WE
DON'T WANT TO DO WE WANT TO SHOW
IS A STATE THAT WE ARE READY TO
IMPLEMENT THESE PROJECTS THAT WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED THE BEST PLACES
TO PUT THEM. WE PRIORITIZE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE WANT TO TRY
TO BRING IN AS MUCH MONEY AS WE
CAN FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND WITHOUT I WOULD ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND I DO HAVE A WITNESS
HERE IN SUPPORT. PLEASE PROCEED
. THANK YOU THE COMMITTEE FOR
LAMA COMMENTS ON THE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR MY
NAME IS DR JUSTIN DELLINGER I'M
WILDLIFE RESEARCH WITH THE UC
DAVIS WILDLIFE HEALTH CENTER A
SPECIALIZED OWN LARGE CARNIVORE
RESEARCH AND I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF STUDYING ASPECTS
OF- CARNIVORE ECOLOGY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WITH A SPECIAL FOCUS
ON. HABITAT CONNECTIVITY. OTHER
RESEARCHERS NINE DEMONSTRATED
THAT VEHICLE STRIKES OUR PRIMARY
SOURCE OF MORTALITY FOR
IMPORTANT SPECIES SUCH AS MOUNT
LINES PARTICULARLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY AREA.
FURTHER NOT LINE'S NOT KILLED BY
VEHICLES IN THESE AREAS ARE
STILL NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
BUSY ROADS. BUSY ROADWAYS ACT AS
BARRIERS AND CREATE ISLANDS OF
HABITAT FOR MOUNTAIN LIONS CAN
BECOME ISOLATED AND EXPERIENCE
INBREEDING. IN FACT THE CURRENT
PETITION TO LIST NOT LINES AS
THREATENED UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT IS
ESSENTIALLY DUE TO THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT OF VEHICLES IN BUSY
ROADWAYS. ON THE SPECIES.
WITHOUT WILDLIFE CROSSING
STRUCTURES TO HELP- MOUNT LINES
CROSS BUSY ROADWAYS THIS TOP
CARNIVORE COULD POSSIBLY GO
EXTINCT IN PART TO CALIFORNIA.
LAW CITIZENS THIS SPECIES COULD
LEAD TO UNRAVELING OF ECOSYSTEMS
REGIONALLY. NOT ONLY ARE
CALIFORNIA'S BUSY ROADWAYS A
THREAT TO EXISTING POPULATIONS
OF NATIVE CARNIVORES LIKE
MOUNTAIN LIONS. THEY'RE ALSO
PROVING TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY TO OTHER CARNIVORES LIKE
GRAY WOLVES TO RECOLONIZE
CALIFORNIA. THE WOLF- ARE NINETY
THREE AS EVIDENCE OF THIS GIVEN
HE WAS HIT AND KILLED BY A
VEHICLE ON OUR FIVE LAST YEAR.
THUS WILDLIFE CROSSING
STRUCTURES ARE NECESSARY TO
ALLEVIATE THE PROBLEMS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED FROM
OUTLINES AND OTHER WILDLIFE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT TO BE EFFECTIVE
RESEARCH ON WILDLIFE MOVEMENT A
GIVEN LOCALE IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
ACROSS AND STRUCTURALLY BUILT.
IN THE BEST LOCATION AND OF THE
CORRECT SPECIFICATIONS. LASTLY
MANY STAFF WITH IMPORTANT STATE
AGENCIES AGREE THAT THESE CROSS
INSTRUCTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
HOWEVER. STAFF IN THE SAME
AGENCIES REGULARLY DEAL WITH
MULTIPLE PRIORITIES AND ARE
UNLIKELY TO BE ABLE TO DEVOTE
THE NECESSARY TIME AND RESOURCES
TOWARDS DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION ACROSS INSTRUCTORS.
UNLESS MANDATED TO DO SO. THUS
IF THIS BILL IS NOT PASSED IT IS
UNLIKELY CROSSING STRUCTURES
WILL BE BUILT. IN CLOSING MUST
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND ACT NOW
TO CONSERVE CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO IS STILL HAVE SOME
ON THE PHONE DO YOU HAVE SOME A
WITNESS ON THE PHONE. FRAZIER
SHELLING YEAH THESE RECEIVING
READY. TO DIRECT YES OKAY GREAT.
HI MY NAME IS SAY THE SELLING
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
VERTICALITY CENTER UC DAVIS
THANKS TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR HEARING MY
SUPPORTIVE TESTIMONY FOR AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR. AS DR
GALLAGHER POINTED OUT WE HAVE A
LOT OF WILDLIFE AND WILDLIFE
HABITAT IN CALIFORNIA. MY CENTER
THE ROAD CALL THE CENTER HAS-
THE LARGEST ROAD KILL REPORTING
SYSTEM OF ITS KIND IN THE U. S.
AND EVERY YEAR WE REPORT TO
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF THIS
ECOLOGICAL HARM. NUMBER ONE THE
PRECISE LOCATIONS OF HOT SPOT
THE COLLISIONS WITH DIVERSE
SPECIES. AND NUMBER TWO THE COST
TO THE DRIVING PUBLIC AND BY
EXTENSION CALIFORNIA THESE
COLLISIONS. OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. OUR SYSTEM TO SHOWN THAT
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS IN COSTS
FROM THESE CRASHES RESULTING
CALIFORNIA. MOST OF THESE COSTS
ARE DUE TO COLLISIONS WITH DEER
AT LEAST AS MANY AS ARE HUNTED
EVERY YEAR. AND ARE FOCUSED ON A
FEW THOUSAND MILES OF HIGHWAY
WHICH ALTHOUGH IT SOUNDS LIKE A
LOT DOES MAKE THE PROBLEM MORE
TRACTABLE. SOMETIMES A LOT OF
DON'T CAUSE ANY DAMAGE TO
VEHICLES LIKE THE THOUSANDS OF
THE PACIFIC NITZER KILLED EVERY
YEAR. ON ABA BRIDGE ROAD IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. BUT THAT
THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE ECOLOGICAL
HARM THAT WERE CAUSING EVERY
TIME WE'RE DRIVING. THROUGH
THEIR HABITAT. WHILE THE VEHICLE
COLLISION DATA IS AN IMPORTANT
WAY THAT WE CAN USE TO DETERMINE
WHERE WILDLIFE CROSSING SHOULD
BE BUILT WHICH IS THE PURPOSE OF
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR. BUT
WE ONLY COLLECT DATA FOR A FEW
PERCENT OF ALL THE COLLISIONS
AND ALL THE ROADWAYS IN
CALIFORNIA. ONE WAY WE COULD
COLLECT MORE DATA ABOUT
COLLISIONS WOULD BE TO
APPROPRIATE FUNDS REST BETWEEN
NINETY FIVE. WHICH INCLUDES A
PUBLIC REPORTING FUNCTION SO FAR
HAS NOT BEEN FUNDED OR HAD ANY
ACTION FROM CDFW- TO MOST OTHER
STATES IN THE WEST CALIFORNIA
BUILDS VERY FEW WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS. AND ENDS SHARE
FRIEDMAN POINTED OUT THAT WILL
LEAVE MONEY ON THE TABLE. ON
FRIDAY CALIFORNIA OFFICIALS WILL
HELP BREAK GROUND FOR THE WALLIS
ANNENBERG WILDLIFE CROSSING. THE
LARGEST WALLET CROSSING BUT IT'S
KIND IN THE WORLD THIS WOULD BE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WHICH
WILL BENEFIT MOUNTAIN LIONS AND
OTHER SPECIES. I BELIEVE AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR WOULD
ALLOW US TO START CATCHING UP TO
OTHER STATES. IN MITIGATING
THESE EXTENSIVE IMPACTS TO
WILDLIFE. AND SO THE CALIFORNIA
VALUES BOTH THIS DIVERSE
WILDLIFE. AND DRIVER SAFETY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
WHEN I GO TO ANYONE IN HERE IN
THE ROOM THAT WANTS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO. AB
TWENTY FORTY FOUR. C. NINE.
OPERATOR HE OPEN THE PHONE LINES
AND SEE IF ANYONE. WANTS TO GO.
DRUMMING WITH THEIR OPINION ON
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
IN JAIL AT THE TIME. OKAY THAT'S
ONE ZERO IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FOUR. FOR YOUR LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON INTERNET AND MEMBERS
ANY GOVERNMENTAL ON BEHALF OF
MEDICINE INTO A REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT. CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION
FUND ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU. EXHORT A LINE NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I GET
AFTERNOON TASHA NEWMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE WILDLANDS CONSERVANCY THE
MOJAVE DESERT LAND TRUST AND
THEN PUT OPEN STATES TRIBES IN
SUPPORT. THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS SANTIAGO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT. NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER
SCORING TALLY- FROM KANSAS CITY
A STRONGER ITS REPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. NOW ALLY NUMBER
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON THE COMMITTEE
NAME IS GAME SPEAKING TODAY
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BERMAN
UNDER STATE ARCHERY ASSOCIATION
THE CAL OR WETLANDS AND
WATERFOWL COUNCIL THE CALIFORNIA
HOUNDS WIN FOR CONSERVATION SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION
THE CALIFORNIA DEER ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE WILD
SHEEP FOUNDATION THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR. NOW THE
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS SYDNEY HOFF WITH RESOLUTE ON
BEHALF OF SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION AND SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN RAISED JANET
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. A SEEING NOTE HERE PERCENT
THIS TO AVOID. NOW WE HAVE NO
PARTISAN Q. PLEASE GO AHEAD ALL
RIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. A SCORE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF AND THE ELECTED
THANK CHAIR FRIEDMAN FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD- I THINK THAT
ESPECIALLY WITH THE- HAVING DFW
ACTUALLY CREATE AN ACTION PLAN-
AND THEN KIND OF. FILL IN THE
DIFFERENT THIS POTENTIAL
PROJECTS IS CRITICAL YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A WILDLIFE QUARTER AND
SOUTHERN PORTIONS SENECA COUNTY
THAT LITERALLY CROSSES. IN FROM
ONE END TO THE NEXT FIVE OR SIX
ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS AND SO IS A REGIONAL STATING OF
WHAT IT REALLY NEEDS TO BE DONE
N A MUCH MORE REGIONAL BASIS.
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND- THE
MOVEMENT PATTERNS AND WHERE
PROJECTS MAKE SENSE OF WHERE
THEY DON'T MAKE SENSE SOMETIMES
PEOPLE THINK THAT ALL I NEED ONE
OF MY DISTRICT BECAUSE AB OR SEE
BUT WHEN YOU ACTUALLY HAD THAT
MORE A COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS TO
DETERMINE WHAT MAKES MOST SENSE
WHAT'S MOST COST EFFECTIVE AS
WELL. I ALSO REALLY LIKE- HAVING
THE ASSESSMENTS OF POTENTIAL
BARRIERS BY THAT BEEN DONE
BEFORE COMMENCING WITH PROJECT
PLANNING WE HAVE SO MANY LEGACY
PROJECTS THAT ARE THAT ARE
NIGHTMARES THAT WE'RE NOW TRYING
TO ENGINEER AROUND OR THROUGH
OVER. A THAT COULD BE AVOIDED
GOING FORWARD- BUT BASED UPON-
OF THIS LEGISLATION SO- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M VERY GRATEFUL
THAT. OF THE CHAIR ALSO LED ME
TO JOIN ON A JOINT AUTHORS AND-
PRETTY HAPPY ABOUT THE BILL
THANK YOU. MISTER GIBSON. REAL
WILL BRIEF- IS IRONIC BECAUSE-
LAST NIGHT I WAS WATCHING-
SOCIAL MEDIA THE TICK TOCK OR
SOMEONE- AND I DON'T THINK IS IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT ON A ROAD IT WAS
SNOWING. AND HIS DRIVER ACTUALLY
HIT A BEAR. AND THE BEAR GOT UP
AND STARTED WALKING FELL DOWN
AGAIN RIGHT- AND THE REASON WHY
I BROUGHT THAT UP BECAUSE I
THINK IT GOES TO WHY WE HAVE TO
HAVE THESE CROSSING WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT. I'M FOR THIS THE
WILDLIFE IS IMPORTANT DON'T KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED BECAUSE THE VIDEO
ON TURNED OFF WITH THE BEAR WAS
AXED WAS ABSOLUTELY FINE CROSS
IT WAS HURT. AND CERTAINLY WE
WANT TO PROTECT OF OUR WILDLIFE
TO THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY I
THINK THIS BILL HELPS US MAKING
SURE- THAT WE DO OUR PART AND SO
I WOULD LIKE TO CONSIDER AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL AT THE CHAIR
WILL ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF BRING IT FOR.
YOU WE PROUD TO HAVE YOU THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS. THE
MANAGER WHICH I TO CLOSE THIS IS
A THAT THE ANNENBERG CROSSING
THAT'S GONE I'M GOING TO ATTEND
THE GRAND OPENING ON FRIDAY
THAT'S RECEIVED HUGE
ENTHUSIASTIC BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN LOS ANGELES PEOPLE ARE VERY
VERY EXCITED ABOUT IT. EVERY
TIME AMOUNT LINE IS FOUND DEAD
ON THE HIGHWAY THE WHOLE CITY
GRIEVES SO I WOULD REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. UNANSWERED
A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR DO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG NOT VOTING
BERMAN. BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
DALY DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES NOT
VOTING GIPSON. GIPSON I KALRA
ALL RIGHT I LI LI I MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN NOT
VOTING. O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I
WORK WARD I WICKS. NINE ZERO.
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT NOW
WE HAVE FIVE MEASURES ON CONSENT
CAN WE PLEASE TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- AND- THE ALSO-
FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT OR SEVEN THE
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE SECTION FIVE OF THE BILL.
WHICH REMOVES PUBLIC FERRY
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
FLEET PURCHASING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FROM THE BILL. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND WAVE
ROLL CALL PLEASE CONSENT ITEMS.
FRIEDMAN I FRIEDMAN HI FONG.
FONG I BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DATE DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON GIPSON HI
KALRA KALRA I LEE ME I'M MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN I
O'DONNELL DONALD I WORK WARD I
WICKS. WELL ZERO THANK YOU CAN
YOU RUN THROUGH THE REST OF THE
ITEMS STARTING CAN. FILE ITEM
THREE AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG NO BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALY. AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. FILE
ITEM THREE. OKAYWITH THAT
DONALD O'DONNELL YOU OF DAILY
DAILY OF STAYING. DAVIES DAVIES
NO GIPSON. GIPSON I KALRA. KALRA
KALRA I LEE B. I MEDINA. MEDINA
I NAZARIAN. WHEN NOT VOTING.
OKAY NOPE OKAY WHEN NO O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL NOT VOTING. WARD
WARD I WICKS. SEVEN THREE SEVEN
THREE. WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
PLEASE GO TO THE NEXT BILL OKAY
FILE ITEM FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX YOU PASSED OF NATURAL
RESOURCES FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FONG. FONG NOT VOTING.
BERMAN BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES. EDUARDO GARCIA. DAVIES I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
KALRA. KALRA I LEE THE I'M
MEDINA. MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN
NOT VOTING. O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
I WORK. WARD I WICKS. AND. ZERO
FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY TO DO PASSED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I FONG
. FONG I BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY I DAVIES
DAVIES I GIPSON GIPSON I KALRA.
ALL RUN NOT VOTING. LEE. B. I
MEDINA MEDINA I THE SYRIAN. WHEN
NOT VOTING. O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
I WARD WARD I. AND. ZERO UNDER
THAT BILL'S OUT NEXT BILL. FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
THREE DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY
AYE DAVIES. DAVIES NOT VOTING.
GIPSON GIPSON I KALRA. KALRA I
WE LEE I'M MEDINA MEDINA I
NAZARIAN. WHEN I O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I WORK WARD I WICKS.
ELEVEN ZERO. ELEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT NEXT BILL. FILE ITEM
NINE AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN
CURRENT VOTE SIX TWO BERMAN.
BERMAN I DALY. DALY I GIPSON
GIPSON I MEDINA MEDINA I WENT.
WHEN NOT VOTING. DONALD WELL
DONALD I WICKS. ELEVEN TO ELEVEN
TO THAT BILL IS OUT NEXT YOU'LL
PLEASE. FILE ITEM TEN B SIXTEEN
SEVENTY NINE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
ZERO BERMAN BERMAN I DAILY.
DAILY I MEDINA MEDINA I. THE
SYRIAN. WHEN I WICKS. YOU.
ELEVEN ZERO. VOTE ELEVEN ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT NEXT BILL. FILE
ITEM TWELVE CURRENT VOTE NINE
ZERO CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY I
MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN. A NEW
VARIANT I WENT. WHEN I WICKS.
THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO THAT
PHYLLIS OUT NEXT BILL. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY TWO ZERO SIX
TO PASS AS AMENDED FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. OF FONG NO
BERMAN. BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
DALY DALY I DAVIES DAVIES NO
GIPSON GIPSON I KALRA ALL RIGHT
I LEE LEE I MEDINA MEDINA I.
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE WHEN NO
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I WARD WARD
I WICKS. TEN THREE. FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
NINE CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY I AS
ARIAN. NAZARIAN I WENT. WHEN I
WICKS. THIRTEEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FOUR. CUNNINGHAM. THIS AREA.
FILE IN FIFTEEN IT'S OKAY.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR NAZARIAN
I WENT. ALTHOUGH SORRY ONCE NOT
VOTING WICKS. AND. ZERO I THINK
MISTER NAZARIAN CAME IN. HELLO
THE LATE SO WE'LL JUST RUN
THROUGH THE ROLE FOR MISSIONS
THERE AND IF YOU DON'T MIND. MR
DALY TO IT AB. THANK. A CONCERT
THE CONSENT ITEMS LET'S SEE HERE
CUNNINGHAM. THE SYRIAN. I WICKS. THIRTEEN ZERO FOR CONSENT
ITEMS ALL RIGHT LET'S START
BACK- FILE ITEM THREE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN THREE. MR THE VARIANT. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN I. A
OF CURRENT VOTE. EIGHT THREE.
LET'S SEE HERE FILE ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX.
BUSINESS YEAR UPGRADE BOTH TEN
ZERO MISTERS ERIN. I OKAY- VOTE. ELEVEN ZERO. AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX. OKAY. FOR VOTE
ELEVEN ZERO A FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO. OCCURRED
ABOUT TEN ZERO MISTER NAZARIAN.
I. FOR VOTER LEVIN ZERO. FILE
ITEM EIGHT TWENTY NINE COMES UP
I'M SORRY FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY THREE CURRENT
VOTE ELEVEN ZERO MISTER NAZARIAN
. THIS ARMY. BROUGH. TWELVE
ZERO. THE FILE ITEM ACTUALLY YOU
YOU DID FILE ITEM NINE OF FILE
ITEM TEN AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE
MISTER NAZARIAN. I. BROUGH.
TWELVE ZERO. AND YOU'RE GOOD TO
GO. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
LEAVE THE VOTE OPEN FOR THE NEXT
TEN MINUTES SO- IF YOU HAVE NOT
TO COME TO COMMITTEE AT USE OF
CHANCE.
ONE
DESCRIBING THE LATTER.
ZERO ZERO.
I LET'S OPEN THE ROLE. ALL RIGHT
ALL OF THIS. GO TO THE CONSENT
ITEMS. KERN VOTE. THIRTEEN ZERO
SIX NINE FOURTEEN ZERO FINAL
VOTE. FILE ITEM OF THREE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT A
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT THREE WICKS.
I FINAL VOTE NINE THREE. FILE
ITEM FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
SIX CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN ZERO
WICKS WICKS I FINAL VOTE TWELVE
ZERO. FILE ITEM FIVE TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY TWO CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
ZERO WICKS WICKS I TWELVE FINAL
VOTE TWELVE ZERO. FILE ITEM S.
SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY THREE
CURRENT BOTH TWELVE ZERO WICKS.
WICKS I. THIRTEEN ZERO FINAL.
FILE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN TWO
WEEKS WICKS I. TWELVE TO FINAL
VOTE FILE ITEM TEN AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY NINE CURRENT VOTE TWELVE
ZERO WICKES WICKES I THIRTEEN
ZERO FINAL. FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN OF KERR
VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO WICKS WICKS I
FOURTEEN ZERO FINAL VOTE. FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY TWO ZERO
SIX CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO WICKS
WIXII. ELEVEN THREE FINAL VOTE.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
NINE FORTY NINE KERN BOTH
THIRTEEN ZERO WICKS WICKS I
FOURTEEN ZERO FINAL VOTE. FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO
WICKS WIXII ELEVEN ZERO FINAL
VOTE. AND THAT IS ALL I HAVE ALL
RIGHT THAT SHOULD INCLUDE THE
TRANSMISSION COMMITTEE HEARING.